Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to The Rest Is History. This is the second episode of our monumental tour through the history of the Football World Cup, which of course is coinciding with the latest iteration of the tournament in Qatar. And Tom, yesterday we were talking about the origins of the World Cup, we were talking about its political significance, the way it had been co-opted by Mussolini in the 1930s,
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验以及加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你好，欢迎收听《历史其余部分》。这是我们回顾足球世界杯历史的宏伟之旅的第二集，当然，这也正值该锦标赛在卡塔尔最新一届比赛举办之际。汤姆，昨天我们讨论了世界杯的起源，讨论了它的政治意义，以及它在20世纪30年代被墨索里尼利用的方式，
but also the way it was wrapped up with nationalism and nation-building and political statements to the world. So we ended in 1950 with Brazil's defeat. We now find ourselves, we have a lot more Brazil to come, but we now find ourselves in 1954 and the entrance into our story of everybody's favorite world cup competitor, the Germans. Yes.
还有它如何与民族主义、国家建设以及对世界的政治表态交织在一起。所以我们以1950年巴西队的失利结束了上一集。现在我们来到了1954年，关于巴西的故事还有很多，但我们现在先来到1954年，迎来我们故事中的主人公——每个人最喜爱的世界杯竞争者，德国人。是的。
So, so we, we said, didn't we, Hitler didn't really, he wasn't a great fan of, of, of football and his focus for his propaganda was obviously the Olympics in 1936.
所以，我们说过，对吧，希特勒其实并不是一个狂热的足球迷，他的宣传重心显然是1936年的奥运会。
There was absolutely a German team. And there was one figure in particular, a man called Sepp Herberger, who had been involved with the infrastructure of the German national team from 1932. The year before, Tom, he joined another organization, the Nazi Party. Right. And so in 1954, when the World Cup is held in Switzerland, he is the German manager. And his diaries cover the entire period from 1932 to 1954. And you can read them and not once in all those diaries is there a single mention of the second world war crikey his focus is very very much on football that is i mean i'm sure he
当时确实有一支德国队。其中有一个特别重要的人物，名叫塞普·赫尔贝格（Sepp Herberger），他从1932年起就参与了德国国家队的建设工作。就在前一年，汤姆，他加入了另一个组织——纳粹党。没错。所以在1954年，当世界杯在瑞士举行时，他是德国队的教练。他的日记涵盖了从1932年到1954年的整个时期。你可以阅读这些日记，但在所有的日记中，竟然没有一次提到第二次世界大战。天哪，他的重心非常非常放在足球上，我的意思是，我相信他
joined the nazi party simply so that he could carry on being involved in the management of the german football team he's very kind of yeah laser visioned. He's from a Catholic family in rural Baden-Württemberg. And yeah, he joined the Nazis, and he's this incredibly kind of wily manager. I mean, actually, Germany had been kicked out of FIFA, Tom, at the end of the Second World War, as had Japan. With Japan, yeah. For poor behavior off the field.
加入纳粹党纯粹是为了能继续参与德国国家队的管理工作。他有一种类似激光般专注的视野。他来自巴登-符腾堡州农村的一个天主教家庭。是的，他加入了纳粹党，而且他是一个极其精明的教练。事实上，德国在二战结束时被国际足联开除了，汤姆，日本也是如此。日本也是，是的。因为他们在场外的恶劣表现。
And actually, interestingly, the English FA, who had bitterly resisted the admission of the old central powers after the First World War, they actually lead the campaign to have the Germans brought back in for 1954. And interestingly, I mean, the war casts a very long shadow. Actually, telling this whole podcast, the Second World War cast a much longer shadow than I had anticipated.
说来有趣，英格兰足总在一战后曾坚决抵制恢复旧同盟国成员的资格，但这次他们却带头开展了一场运动，让德国人在1954年重返国际足联。而且有趣的是，战争留下了非常长远的阴影。实际上，贯穿整个播客，第二次世界大战留下的阴影比我预期的要长得多。
Yeah. So the Germans actually play. Do you know who they play to qualify for the World Cup? No. They play the Saarland. Oh, yes, I do. Yes, of course. So the Saarland, which is obviously part of Germany,
是的。所以德国队确实参加了比赛。你知道他们为了获得世界杯资格跟谁踢的吗？不知道。他们踢了萨尔兰。噢，对，我知道。是的，当然。萨尔兰显然是德国的一部分，
had been detached from Germany at the end of the Second World War and made into a French protectorate and was only allowed to rejoin West Germany after a referendum. So the Saarland actually participates separately in the World Cup in 1954. But also we've mentioned the manager, the captain, Fritz Wolter, had been a paratrooper on the Eastern Front, hadn't he? Yes. And he was about to be shipped off to Siberia when, what is it a hungarian it's an amazing guard kind of spots him and remembers him from a match
在二战结束时从德国分离出来，成为了法国的保护国，直到经过全民公投后才被允许重新加入西德。所以萨尔兰在1954年的世界杯上是作为独立队伍参赛的。此外，我们刚才提到了教练，队长弗里茨·瓦尔特（Fritz Walter）曾是东线战场的一名伞兵，对吧？是的。他当时正要被押送到西伯利亚，这时，是一个匈牙利人，这是一个神奇的卫兵认出了他，并记起了他曾在一场比赛中
germany and hungary had played amazing story so he's one of these people who herberger manages to protect his players from serving on the front lines in the second world war so walter is a paratrooper but he's kept behind the lines but he's captured at the end of the war first by the americans and then he's handed over to the Russians. And it looks like he's going to go off to Siberia. Basically, if you go to Siberia, you either stay there forever or you die. And it's exactly that. So the guards and prisoners are having a kick around a football or something.
德国和匈牙利交过手，这是一个神奇的故事。所以他是赫尔贝格设法保护其免受二战前线服役之苦的球员之一。瓦尔特是一名伞兵，但被留在了后方，不过他在战争结束时被俘虏，先是被美国人俘虏，然后被移交给苏联人。看起来他要被送往西伯利亚了。基本上，如果你去了西伯利亚，要么永远呆在那里，要么死在那里。事实也确实如此。所以卫兵和囚犯们正在踢着足球或者别的东西解闷。
Walter gets kind of involved, and the Hungarian guard says to him, I know you. Didn't you play against us in Budapest? And the next day, his name is removed from the lists and he's allowed to go home. And he repays the Hungarians, Tom. Yes, by defeating them in the final. By stamping on their dreams.
瓦尔特也参与其中，一个匈牙利卫兵对他说：“我认识你。你不是在布达佩斯和我们踢过球吗？”第二天，他的名字就从名单上被划掉了，并被允许回家。而他报答匈牙利人的方式，汤姆，是的，就是在决赛中击败他们。是将他们的梦想踩在脚下。
So Hungary are by far the best, aren't they? They are the team that should have won the 1954 World Cup. They had been unbeaten for four years before the tournament. They had this rich tradition. I mean, Jonathan Wilson, who we talked about in the last podcast, his brilliant history of Argentina, he's also written a brilliant history of Hungary.
所以匈牙利队是毫无疑问最强的，对吧？他们本该赢得1954年世界杯。在锦标赛开始前的四年里，他们保持不败。他们拥有深厚的传统。我的意思是，我们在上期播客中讨论过的乔纳森·威尔逊（Jonathan Wilson），他不仅写了关于阿根廷的出色历史，也写了一本关于匈牙利的出色历史。
And he sort of has this theory that Hungarian football was incredibly innovative in mid-century because of coffeehouses, because people would spread out in coffee houses designing tactics and certainly the hungarians they are by far the best team in europe if not the world they had famously been the first team to beat england in england at wembley at the empire stadium victory for communism over imperialism 6-3 in 1953 they they get to the final in the wankdorf stadium in berg most amusingly yes i knew you'd enjoy that i knew you'd enjoy that i i wanted to get in before you uh they go 2-0 up and they've actually already played germany already in the tournament and beat them 8-3 so and it's the classic thing you know so often in the world cup they go 2-0 up and at that point
他有一个这样的理论：匈牙利足球在世纪中期之所以极具创新精神，是因为咖啡馆文化的兴起，人们在咖啡馆里铺开纸张设计战术。当然，匈牙利人绝对是欧洲乃至世界上最强的球队。他们曾在1953年的温布利球场——帝国体育场，历史性地以6比3击败英格兰，成为第一支在英格兰本土击败英格兰的球队，这是共产主义对帝国主义的胜利。他们一路杀入位于伯尔尼的万克多夫体育场参加决赛。最有趣的是，是的，我知道你会喜欢的，我知道你会喜欢的，我本想抢在你前面……他们取得了2比0的领先，而且他们在小组赛中其实就已经和德国交过手并以8比3大胜对手。所以，这是一种经典的情况，你知道，在世界杯上经常发生这种情况：当你取得2比0领先时，在那一刻，
you know that you know, disaster beckons. Well, you let your foot off the accelerator, I guess. That's exactly what happens. The Germans come back. The Germans win 3-2. And Ferenc Puskas and these amazing Hungarian players never get the gold that they deserve. So the manager, the captain, both obviously have played their role in in the second world war is it also true this and this is a story again so in the first episode we talked about these
你就知道，灾难就要降临了。嗯，你放松了对油门的踩踏，我想。情况确实如此。德国队反扑了。德国队以3比2获胜。费伦茨·普斯卡什（Ferenc Puskas）和这些出色的匈牙利球员永远没有得到他们应得的金牌。所以教练和队长显然都在二战中扮演了各自的角色，还有一个传言是否也是真的呢？这又是一个故事，在第一集里我们讨论过这些
legends that grow up and they they're impossible to prove there is a story isn't there that all the germans were on amphetamines yeah i think that this is a legacy of the uh the Luftwaffe pilots using them to stay awake i think that's dubious i've seen that repeated a lot um but again as we said in the first podcast the trouble is there's allegations but there's no hard evidence and what always happens with the history of the world cup is the allegations or speculation soon turn into supposedly hard facts repeated endlessly recycled without anybody ever really checking whether the origins of the stories are true now you mentioned the reaction so first of all in hungary where the hungarian
流传开来的传奇故事，但它们根本无法证实。有这样一个传言，对吧？说所有德国球员都服用了安非他命。是的，我认为这是卢夫特瓦夫（Luftwaffe，德国空军）飞行员用它们来保持清醒的遗留影响，我觉得这有些可疑。我看到这个说法被重复了很多次，但正如我们在第一期播客中所说，问题在于有指控却没有确凿证据。而世界杯历史上经常发生的情况是，指控或猜测很快就会变成所谓的硬事实，被无休止地重复和循环，而没有人真正去查证这些故事的起源是否真实。现在你提到了各方的反应，首先在匈牙利，匈牙利
team were absolute national heroes they become villains overnight there are demonstrations there are you know they can't go home at first the goalkeeper doesn't have to burn the gold paste no like the brazilian yeah i mean actually and the hungarian team it's only two years before the hungarian uprising and most of the the it's only two years before the Hungarian uprising, and most of the top, well, at least some of the top players end up fleeing to the West. So Pushkic, the captain, he ends up playing for Real Madrid. Ghibor and Kokcic, they end up playing for Barcelona and so on.
球队曾经是绝对的民族英雄，却在一夜之间变成了恶棍。爆发了游行抗议，他们一开始甚至无法回家。守门员甚至不用烧掉金发膏，不像巴西队那样。我的意思是，而且匈牙利国家队——距离匈牙利十月事件仅仅两年时间，而且大多数顶级球员，或者说至少其中一些顶级球员，最终都逃往了西方。所以队长普斯卡什最终去了皇家马德里效力。齐博尔（Czibor）和柯奇什（Kocsis）最终去了巴塞罗那效力，诸如此类。
So that's kind of the end of Hungary. It's a tragic story, actually, because that's the end of Hungary as a force. The mighty Magyars. But actually, so I thought when we were preparing as a as a as a force the mighty magyars but actually so i thought when we were preparing this that this would be a story about hungary but what's much more interesting is germany so it's called it's called the miracle of burn because the germans were so unfancied and they came back to win three two their first world cup after the second world war and subsequently, people like Joachim Fest,
所以匈牙利足球的故事就这样结束了。这其实是一个悲剧故事，因为这是匈牙利作为足球强国的终结。伟大的马扎尔人（Magyars）。不过，当我准备这一集时，我以为这会是一个关于匈牙利的故事，但更有趣的是德国。所以它被称为“伯尔尼奇迹”，因为德国队并不被看好，但他们逆转以3比2获胜，赢得了二战后的第一座世界杯冠军。随后，诸如约阿希姆·费斯特（Joachim Fest）——
the great West German historian, said, this moment, this match was the true birth of the country. And there's this phrase... Well, it's the first time that the National Anthem has been played since the Second World War, I think, in public. Well, well. Is that right?
伟大的西德历史学家——这样的人说，这个时刻、这场比赛才是这个国家的真正诞生。并且有这样一句话……嗯，这也是自二战以来第一次在公开场合演奏国歌，我想。是吗？
I don't know if it's the first time, but the National Anthem is a bit of a story, Tom. Because... Well, yes. So everybody sort of says... So traditionally, and this is the story that FIFA tell about the 1954 World Cup, it's a lovely story about reconciliation
我不知道这是否是第一次，但关于国歌本身还有一个故事，汤姆。因为……好吧，是的。所以每个人都这么说……传统上，这也是国际足联关于1954年世界杯的官方说法，这是一个关于二战后和解的美丽故事，
after the Second World War and the Germans, you know, being rebuilt as a modern progressive nation. And the Germans associate it with the phrase via sint vida ver, we are somebody again. Lovely. Unfortunately, there is some evidence that the Germans had not perhaps
德国人（你知道的）被重塑为一个现代进步的国家。德国人将此与“我们再次成为某个人”（Wir sind wieder wer）这句话联系起来。很美好。不幸的是，有一些证据表明，德国人可能并没有
changed as much as one might hope. So I reviewed a book last year called Aftermath by a German writer, a German historian called Harald Jena. And the real shocking revelation of that book, the story of that book, is actually how little Germany changed in the 1950s. I mean, Jena's book is incredible, sort of revisionist, and he has all this stuff about surveys and polls showing that lots of Germans, long after Hitler's death, had not reneged on their kind of Nazi commitments or their ideological affiliations. So what happens at the final?
像人们所希望的那样发生彻底的改变。所以我去年评论了一本名为《余波》（Aftermath）的书，作者是一位德国作家、德国历史学家哈拉尔德·杰纳（Harald Jena）。那本书真正令人震惊的启示、那本书的故事，实际上是德国在20世纪50年代的变化是多么微乎其微。我的意思是，杰纳的书非常了不起，具有某种修正主义色彩，里面包含了大量关于民意调查和问卷的数据，表明许多德国人在希特勒死后很久，并没有背叛他们对纳粹的承诺或意识形态归属。那么在决赛时发生了什么？
Some of the German fans do sing the national anthem but they refuse to sing the new words they sing Deutschland Deutschland
一些德国球迷确实唱了国歌，但他们拒绝唱新的歌词，他们唱的是“德意志，德意志，
Uber Alice but the real shocking thing is the president of the German Football Association who's a man
高于一切”（Deutschland Deutschland über alles）。但真正令人震惊的是德国足球协会的主席，一个名叫
called Pico Balvens he holds a celebration in a Munich beer cellar what could possibly go wrong
皮科·鲍温斯（Pico Bauwens）的人，他在慕尼黑的一个啤酒馆里举办了一场庆祝活动，这究竟能出什么差错呢？
a beer hall and Tom not just any Munich beer hall so the original beer possibly go wrong? A beer hall. And Tom, not just any Munich beer hall. So the original beer hall where Hitler had had the beer hall putsch in the 1920s, where the Nazis always used to assemble for the anniversary every year, that had been blown up in a bomb in, I think, 1939. So they had moved their annual celebration
一个啤酒馆。汤姆，还不是普通的慕尼黑啤酒馆。所以原本的啤酒馆——希特勒在20世纪20年代发动啤酒馆政变的地方，纳粹每年都在那里集会庆祝周年纪念的地方，在1939年（我想是吧）的一次炸弹袭击中被炸毁了。所以他们把年度庆祝活动搬到了
to a different beer hall nearby. This is the beer hall that the FA president decides he will have the meeting and celebrate victory and does he celebrate their furor princip he does he says basically he says to the players your victory is a victory for the furor princip the furor principal and you were inspired by the spirit of the god votan but i i mean to be be fair, the Führer is probably not Hitler, there is it. It's Herberger, the manager. Yeah, unfortunately, Bauwens had been a Nazi party member himself, had been a Nazi party member since 1933.
附近另一家不同的啤酒馆。这就是足协主席决定举行会议庆祝胜利的啤酒馆，而且他是在歌颂元首原则（Führerprinzip）吗？他确实这么做了，他基本上对球员们说：“你们的胜利是元首原则的胜利，你们受到了战神沃坦精神的鼓舞。”不过，说句公道话，这里的“元首”可能指的不是希特勒，而是教练赫尔贝格。是的，不幸的是，鲍温斯本人曾是一名纳粹党员，从1933年起就是纳粹党员。
And Tom, you think that, but lots of Germans listening to that did not take such a charitable view, including the president of the West German Republic, who gives a speech a few days later reprimanding Bauwens for this incredibly inflammatory speech about the Führerprinzip and all this sort of stuff. And the German papers sort of go out of their way to try and distance themselves, but the damage has actually been done.
汤姆，你可能会这么想，但许多听到这话的德国人并没有采取如此宽容的看法，其中包括西德共和国总统，他在几天后发表了一次演讲，公开谴责鲍温斯发表了关于元首原则以及诸如此类极其煽动性的言论。德国报纸也竭尽全力试图与此划清界限，但损害实际上已经造成了。
And this is, I didn't know any of this until I started researching it. In East Germany, the newspapers, the communist papers, seize on this and they say, I mean, amazing lines. When fascists start singing Deutschland über alles in a horse vessel song, that has nothing to do with sport. That has to do with death, says the East German papers. And they say of Fritz Walter, he once wore a Wehrmacht uniform. He could say that luckily for him, the war ended
而这些，在我开始做研究之前我全都不知情。在东德，报纸，那些共产主义报纸，抓住了这一点并大加挞伐，他们说——这些言论太惊人了——“当法西斯分子开始在沙文主义歌曲中唱起‘德意志高于一切’时，这与体育毫无关系。这与死亡有关，”东德报纸如是说。他们谈到弗里茨·沃尔特时说，他曾穿过德国国防军的军服，虽然对他来说幸运的是战争以被苏联关押而告终，但其他球员就没那么幸运并在战争中丧生了。为什么我们现在还要纪念他们？因为康拉德·阿登纳（西德基督教民主联盟的总理）的政策，显然是在重蹈希特勒的覆辙。所以你会料到东德报纸会这么说。来看看英国的《每日镜报》是怎么说的，汤姆，
with Soviet imprisonment, but other players were not so lucky and were killed. Why do we need to remember them now? Because the policies of Konrad Adenauer, that's the Christian Democrat Chancellor of West Germany, they are clearly steering the same course as Hitler. So you'd expect the East German papers to say that. See what the Daily Mirror said Tom in Britain did yes nothing can stop these unlovable people here comes swaggering Germany German businesses swarm all over Europe even in football not a noticeably German sport they wipe out the Hungarians but it's not just the British is it the Danes the Danes all that was all that was lacking at the final whistle was the Seagal and the most
是的，没什么能阻挡这些不可爱的家伙，狂妄自大的德国人来了。德国企业在全欧洲蜂拥而至，甚至在足球这个并非显眼具有德国特色的运动中，他们也击败了匈牙利人。但这不仅仅是英国人，还有丹麦人。丹麦人说，决赛哨响时，唯一缺少的就是纳粹礼。而最
striking one actually given that the Franco-German rapprochement with the birth of the European community is Le Monde
引人注目的反应，考虑到法德和解与欧洲共同体的诞生，实际上来自《世界报》（Le Monde）。
Pierre Faber their star columnist says the memory of these thousands of German fanatics who went to support their team
皮埃尔·法贝（Pierre Faber），他们的一位明星专栏作家说：“这些成千上万前往支持他们球队的德国狂热分子的记忆
will be lasting sport certainly but not only sport fanaticism revenge Uber Alice, Herberger, Weimar, Adenauer, the European defence community. That is how it all begins again. I mean...
将是持久的。这当然是体育，但不仅仅是体育；狂热、复仇、高于一切、赫尔贝格、魏玛、阿登纳、欧洲防务共同体。这一切就是这样重新开始的。”我的意思是……
Okay, well, so I didn't know that. I didn't know that. I had always thought that it was a monument to European reconciliation. No. So the next two World Cups are held in Sweden and Chile, and Brazil wins them both. And we will come to Brazil. But let's just stick on the theme of Germany and England's attitudes to Germany,
好吧，我以前并不知道这些。我真的不知道。我一直以为这是一个欧洲和解的丰碑。并不是。接下来的两届世界杯分别在瑞典和智利举行，巴西队连续赢得了这两届冠军。我们稍后会聊到巴西。但让我们继续聚焦于德国以及英国对德国的态度，
because in 1966, as all English listeners will know, the World Cup comes to England, and England ended up winning. And I had always assumed, having grown up against a background of tabloids every time england played germany reaching for the second world war metaphors that the same had been true in 1966 yeah but apparently this is not the case there weren't too many uh it wasn't kind of wall-to-wall second world war not wall-to-wall jingoism there Not wall-to-wall. Jingoism. There's a bit, though. The Daily Mail, Tom.
因为正如所有英国听众所知，在1966年，世界杯来到了英格兰，并且最终由英格兰夺冠。我一直以为，成长在每当英格兰对阵德国时小报就会搬出二战隐喻的背景下，1966年也是如此。是的，但显然并非如此。当时并没有太多……并没有全方位的二战回忆，也没有全方位的沙文主义。并不是全方位的沙文主义。不过还是有一点。《每日镜报》，汤姆。
I mean, great newspaper. Well, if the Germans beat us at Wembley this afternoon at our national sport, we could always point out to them that we've recently beaten them twice at theirs. Yes, fine. But that's kind of, I mean, that is the kind of knockabout. The stuff about goose steps and SIG Heil and all that kind of stuff that follows the 54. I mean, that's a different order of paranoia. Yes, I suppose so. I think you're right that there's, oh yeah, but I mean, perhaps we shouldn't be too harsh because it's only nine years after the end of the war. But it turns out to be paranoia.
我的意思是，这是一份伟大的报纸。好吧，“如果德国人在今天下午的温布利球场在我们自己的国球上击败我们，我们总可以向他们指出，我们最近在他们的运动上击败过他们两次。”是的，没问题。但这只是一种，我的意思是，这只是一种调侃。而那些在1954年之后随之而来的关于鹅步、纳粹礼之类的东西，那是完全不同等级的偏执。是的，我想是的。我想你是对的，哦是的，不过也许我们不应该太严厉，因为毕竟这距离二战结束才仅仅九年。但事实证明这确实是偏执。
Yes, it turns out to be paranoia. Yes, it turns out to be paranoia. Because Adonair is not a fascist. Yeah, agreed. West Germany becomes a kind of model liberal democracy. Yes, agreed. And by 1966, it's evident that German democracy is in very rude health. That's absolutely fair. Yes, and actually the British stuff in 1966 is pantomime. It's a joke.
是的，事实证明这确实是偏执。是的，事实证明这确实是偏执。因为阿登纳并不是一个法西斯分子。是的，没错。西德变成了一种模范的自由民主政体。是的，没错。到1966年，很明显德国的民主状况非常健康。这绝对是公允的。是的，事实上英国人在1966年的那些言论只是一种滑稽剧。这只是个玩笑。
It's not as a, yeah. And the whole story of the world cup in 1966 is very very carry on so we've up to now it's all been we've all had dictators and shadows and murders and deaths and all kind of stuff 1966 yes it's an ealing comedy it's a carry-on film whatever so we mentioned in the previous part that um the jewelry made trophy is like the statue of marduk in babylon people kept nicking it and it gets stolen doesn't it before the world cup begins yeah and then it gets found in very suspicious circumstances by a dog called pickles well i mean that and the story is that
这并不是一种……是的。而且1966年世界杯的整个故事都非常像英国的《滑稽喜剧》（Carry On）系列电影。所以到目前为止，之前所有的故事都充满了独裁者、阴影、谋杀、死亡和各种各样的事情，而1966年，是的，它就像一部伊灵喜剧（Ealing comedy），一部《滑稽喜剧》电影，诸如此类。所以我们在上一部分提到过，朱尔·里米杯奖杯就像巴比伦的马尔杜克雕像一样，人们总是不断地偷它，结果在世界杯开始前它真的被偷了，对吧？
pickles sniffs it out but you don't sniff out a trophy a trophy so quite what is going on there so it's always been slightly confusing. So it was stolen from a stamp exhibition. I mean, that tells you just the slightly dowdy image of the World Cup, that they had a stamp exhibition at the Methodist Central Hall in Westminster, that the thief ignored all these incredibly valuable stamps with a value of supposedly £3 million pounds to steal the trophy, which was worth much less.
然后在一只名叫“泡菜”（Pickles）的狗的帮助下，在非常可疑的情况下被找到了。我的意思是，那个故事是说“泡菜”嗅出了奖杯的下落，但你不可能靠鼻子闻出奖杯，奖杯又不是靠气味找到的。所以这背后到底发生了什么？这其实一直有点令人困惑。奖杯是从一个邮票博览会上被偷的。我的意思是，这说明了世界杯当时那种略显寒酸的形象：他们竟然在威斯敏斯特的卫理公会中央大厅举办了一个邮票博览会，而小偷竟然无视所有那些据称价值300万英镑的极其珍贵的邮票，反而去偷了那个价值要低得多的奖杯。
There's a ransom demand for 15,000 pounds. What a fool. Where didn't he steal the stamps? 15,000 pounds. Why didn't he steal the stamps? Anyway, this bloke called David Corbett, who's a lighterman on the Thames.
当时还有一个15000英镑的勒索赎金要求。真是个笨蛋。他怎么不偷邮票呢？15000英镑。他为什么不顺便偷邮票呢？不管怎样，这个叫大卫·科比（David Corbett）的人，他是泰晤士河上的一名驳船船工。
David Corbett is a very 1960s sitcom name. It is. He's a bargeman. And his dog, Pickles, finds the trophy. Discovers it. Discovers it, wrapped in newspaper by a car in Upper Norwood, London. Corbett is given a reward of £5,000. So that actually, I mean, the £15,000, it's not nothing,
大卫·科比听起来非常像是1960年代情景喜剧里的名字。确实是的。他是一名船工。他的狗“泡菜”找到了这个奖杯。发现了它。
because £5,000 is the equivalent to about £100,000 today. He uses the money to buy himself a house in Surrey, Tom. Yeah. Pickles is given a medal. Pickles becomes a national hero. He's in a film. He's in a film. He's in a film, and he goes to the celebratory dinner
发现了它，当时奖杯被报纸包裹着，扔在伦敦上诺伍德的一辆汽车旁边。科比获得了5000英镑的奖金。所以实际上，我的意思是，15000英镑赎金并不是个小数目，因为5000英镑相当于今天的100,000英镑左右。他用这笔钱在萨里郡给自己买了一栋房子，汤姆。是的。“泡菜”被授予了一枚奖牌。“泡菜”成了国家英雄。它还参演了一部电影。它参演了一部电影。它参演了一部电影，并且在英格兰队夺冠后的庆祝晚宴上也出席了，对吧？是的。它是球队中受到荣誉的成员之一。我的意思是，我猜它才不在乎什么晚宴呢，它只是一条狗。但后来它在悲惨的情况下死去了。天哪，可怕的情况。它的牵引绳被树枝缠住了。
after England win, doesn't he? He does. He's a kind of honoured member of the team. I mean, he doesn't give a damn about the dinner, I imagine. He's a dog. But then he dies in tragic circumstances. Gosh, terrible circumstances. His lead gets tangled on a branch.
是的。所以它基本上是把自己给吊死了，这非常令人悲哀。天哪。所以我们之前有吉图利奥·瓦加斯在上一集中自杀的巴西独裁者，现在又轮到了“泡菜”。我骄傲地说，英格兰是第一个拥有吉祥物的国家，那就是“世界杯威利”（World Cup Willie）。
Yes. So he basically hangs himself, which is very sad. God almighty. So we had Getulio Vargas taking his own life, the Brazilian dictator in the last episode, and now Pickles. England is, I'm proud to say, is the first to feature a mascot, World Cup Willie.
哦，对，“世界杯威利”，是的。所以这很棒。而从地缘政治的角度来看，最有趣的故事是朝鲜队的出现。哦，对，你最喜欢这个故事了，汤姆。嗯，它绝对是一个隐士王国。我的意思是，它就是那个样子。总的来说，它并不以参与国际体育赛事而闻名。
Oh, yes, World Cup Willie, yeah. So that's great. And geopolitically, the most interesting story is the presence of North Korea. Oh, yeah, you love this story, Tom. Well, it's absolutely a hermit kingdom. I mean, it is as it is. By and large, it's not famous for its engagement in international sporting events.
没有。但他们在附加赛中击败澳大利亚获得了参赛资格。他们去了米德尔斯堡。是的，艾尔森公园球场（Ayresome Park）。他们在艾尔森公园球场比赛。米德尔斯堡的人民对朝鲜队敞开了胸怀。朝鲜队甚至赢了。我想，继1950年巴西世界杯英格兰0比1输给美国（这可能是世界杯历史上最大的冷门）之后，
No. But they qualify by beating Australia in a playoff. And they go to Middlesbrough. Yeah, Ayersin Park. And they play at Ayersin Park. And the people of Middlesbrough take the Koreans to their heart. And the North Koreans win. I guess after England losing to America 1-0 in the Brazilian World Cup in 1950, probably the biggest upset in World Cup history,
意大利以0比1输给朝鲜，大概就是世界杯历史上第二大冷门了。朴斗翼（Pak Doo-ik）非常著名地打进了那个进球。所以朴斗翼和乔纳森·威尔逊——我们在这些节目中经常提到这位伟大的足球历史学家……你得停止和线人一起去吃晚宴了。好吧，他告诉我一个非常神奇的故事，关于——所以这个谜团是，朝鲜队
that Italy lose to North Korea 1-0. Pac Duik scored the goal very famously. So Pac Duik and Jonathan Wilson, we've been mentioning a lot in these programs, the great Diana football history. You've got to stop going for dinner with informants. Okay, so he told me this fabulous story about, so the mystery, so North Korea,
他们闯入了下一轮，并去了利物浦，据说他们在那里被洛约拉大厦（Loyola House）的宗教圣像吓坏了。是这样的吗？洛约拉大厅（Loyola Hall），他们被安顿在那里，你知道，那里有巴洛克风格的圣母雕像和正在流血至死的耶稣以及各种各样的东西。他们被这些东西吓坏了，据说这严重影响了他们的状态，
they get through to the next round and they go to Liverpool, where apparently they are freaked out by the religious iconography of Loyola House. Is that right? Loyola Hall, where they've been put up, you know, the kind of Baroque statues of the Virgin and Jesus bleeding to death and all kinds of things. And they're so freaked out by this that apparently it puts them off their stride
导致他们输了球并返回了国内。所以关于他们身上到底发生了什么，流传着各种各样的都市传说。是的。比如传言他们都被枪决了，或者因为表现不好被送去拔鸡毛的工厂之类的。但实际上，他们似乎受到了很高的礼遇。乔纳森说——可能我的记忆有点模糊了，如果我记错了而且乔纳森正在听的话，向他道歉——艾尔森公园球场后来被拆了。是的，这个确实发生了。他们在球场原址上建了一个住宅小区，但他们特意在艾尔森公园球场历史上神圣的地方做出了标记，其中之一就是朴斗翼打进帮助朝鲜击败意大利的制胜球的那个位置。是的，打进了制胜球，这是很棒的足球专业术语，
and they lose and go back. So there are all kinds of urban myths about what happened to them. Yeah. And the stories that they all got shot or they got sent off to chicken plucking factories or whatever for not but actually they seem to have been treated with great honor and jonathan said that that and i may be slightly garbling this and if i am and jonathan's listening apologies to him but airson park gets pulled down it does well that definitely did happen so they build a kind of housing estate where it had stood but they make sure to mark out particular places that kind of holy in the history of airson park and one of them is the spot where pak do it hit the winning strike that enabled north korea to beat italy yeah hit the winning strike that's great footballing terminology
汤姆。不管怎样，不管谁进的球，怎么……不，不是那个。是球所在的位置，他起脚射门得分。所以这就是被标记的地方。这就是他当时站着、起脚踢球的那个点。是的。然后有一天人们，你知道的，
tom well whatever what scored the goal how would, no, but it's not that. It's, it's, it's the spot where the ball is and he kicks it to go in. So that is what, that's what's marking it. It's the point where he's standing, where he kicks the ball. Yeah. And one day people are kind of, you know,
在自己的家里听到唱歌的声音，于是他们走出门去。我想这是在2002年，他们走出门，发现当年参加那场比赛的所有朝鲜队成员、那些在世的球员们，正围站在那个地点唱着一首歌。我不知道他们在唱什么，但他们很可能是在唱歌。所以他们是以某种朝圣的形式来到这里，来纪念——我认为这个故事实际上是真的，汤姆。我认为这是真的。
in their, in their homes and they hear this sound of singing and they go out. I think this is 2002 they go out and all the members of the north korean team who played in that match the surviving members are standing around the spot singing a song i don't know what they were singing but they were singing a song probably and so they come on a kind of they come on a pilgrimage to to to commemorate the uh i think that story is actually true, Tom. It is true, I think.
他们是作为拍电影的一部分被带过来的。是由一位纪录片制作人带来的，完全是这样。所以非常感人。是的。而且显然米德尔斯堡和朝鲜之间的关系就像和英国任何其他地方一样好。我很想说，汤姆，
They were brought over for film. As part of a film. By a documentary maker, exactly. So very moving. Yeah. And apparently the relationship between Middlesbrough and North Korea is as good as with anywhere in Britain. I'm tempted to say, Tom,
去过米德尔斯堡的人根本分不清两者的区别。但这将是一个可怕的……你不会那样说吧？我才不会那么低级呢。但是来自米德尔斯堡的球队去朝鲜踢过比赛。这不是大多数人会做的事。没有。所以这是一个非常感人的故事。
that people who've been to Middlesbrough can't tell the difference. But that would be a terrible... You're not going to do that, are you? I wouldn't be so cheap. But teams from Middlesbrough can't tell the difference. But that would be a terrible, that would be a shocking thing to say. And I wouldn't be so cheap. But teams from Middlesbrough go and play in North Korea. And that's not something that most people do. No. So that's a very touching story.
另一个大故事，我想，就是英格兰对阵阿根廷。英格兰在四分之一决赛中遇到了阿根廷。是的。在第一部分中，我们谈到了是英国人把足球带到了阿根廷。对阿根廷人来说，英国仍然是足球的发源地，也是他们用西班牙语所称的“公平竞赛”（el fair play）的发源地。
The other, I guess, the big story is England against Argentina. So England meet Argentina in the quarterfinal. Yeah. And in the first part, we talked about how it's the English who bring football to Argentina. And for Argentina, England remains the home of football, and it's the home of what in Spanish they call el fair play. El fair play.
嗯，还有英国，正如我们在福克兰群岛播客中讨论的那样，对阿根廷人具有非常特殊的意义，因为英国曾是他们19世纪大部分时期的模范。英国曾是那种非正式的殖民霸主，某种经济霸主。但阿根廷也有一种谈论“英国海盗”的传统。是的。
Well, also Britain, as we've talked about in our Falklands podcast, Britain has a very particular significance for Argentines because it was the model for much of the 19th century. It was the kind of informal colonial overlord, the sort of economic overlord. But also there's this whole tradition in Argentina of talking about English piracy. Yeah.
他们所看到的，是对马尔维纳斯群岛（福克兰群岛）的窃取。是的。所以当英格兰对阵阿根廷时，总是带有某种宿敌对决的意味，即使一开始英国人并没有真正意识到这一点。是的。但在四分之一决赛中，他们确实意识到了。
And what they see is the theft of Las Malvinas, the Falkland Islands. Yeah. So when England played Argentina, there was always an element of being a grudge match, even if at first the English didn't really notice. Yes. And in the quarterfinal, they do notice.
英国媒体对此事的报道是，阿根廷人的表现极其卑劣。所以阿尔夫·拉姆齐（Alf Ramsey），这位曾在1950年巴西世界杯上踢过球的教练——他确实踢过。他禁止自己的球员与阿根廷球员交换球衣。他称，是的。他禁止自己的球员与阿根廷球员交换球衣。他称他们为“动物”。英格兰球员阿兰·鲍尔（Alan Ball）说，这是他职业生涯中交手过的最肮脏、最卑鄙的球队。要知道，我可是年复一年地跟唐·里维（Don Revie）的利兹联交手过。这对利兹联球迷来说绝对是一个辛辣的讽刺。这是一个极其严厉的谴责，休·麦克韦尼（Hugh McIlvanney）甚至将这场比赛形容为与其说是一场足球赛，不如说是一起国际事件。这给英国人留下了一种根深蒂固的印象：阿根廷人很肮脏、是骗子、会吐口水、充满暴力。而在阿根廷，这种感觉完全一样，他们认为英国人的表现极其卑劣，踢球时充满了粗暴的铲球和非常非常暴力的行为。而其中的导火索时刻是，阿根廷队长
And the way it's reported by the British press is that the Argentines behaved disgracefully. And so Alf Ramsey, the manager who played in 1950, hadn't he, in Brazil? He had. He bans his players from swapping shirts with the Argentine players. He calls, yeah. He bans his players from swapping shirts with the Argentine players. He calls them animals. Alan Ball, England player, says that they were the dirtiest, filthiest team I ever played against in my career. And remember, I played against Revy's Leeds year in, year out. That's one for the Leeds fans. Damning condemnation there. And Hugh McIverney described it not so much a football match as an international incident. And so that set the seal on the English sense that the Argentines are dirty, that they're cheats, that they spit, that they're violent. The sense in Argentina is exactly the same, that the English behaved disgracefully, that they were hacking and very, very violent play. And the lightning rod moment is when the Argentine captain,
安东尼奥·拉廷（Antonio Rattin）被一名不会说西班牙语的德国裁判罚下场。是的，因为说脏话。因为说脏话。裁判怎么可能听得懂呢？他根本不可能听懂。据说拉廷当时是在找翻译。你一定是听信了所有这些威尔逊式的阿根廷宣传。
Antonio Rattin, gets sent off by a German referee who doesn't speak Spanish. Yeah, for swearing. For swearing. And how could the referee know that? He couldn't know that. And apparently Rattin was asking for a translator. You've been listening to all this Wilsonian Argentine propaganda.
确实如此。拉廷离场了，据说他走过——他被罚下了场，一脸难以置信，完全不知道发生了什么。他从一面印有英国国旗的旗帜旁走过，并对它做了一个手势。乔纳森暗示，这个手势表达了他对“公平竞赛发源地”竟然能表现得如此糟糕的怀疑。你怎么能用手势表达怀疑呢？
I have. And Rattin goes off and apparently he walks past the – he gets sent off, disbelieving, not quite knowing what's happened. And he walks past one of the flags on which there are Union Jacks emblazoned, and he makes a gesture to it. And Jonathan suggests that this is a gesture expressing his doubt that the home of El Fair Play could have behaved so badly. How do you make a gesture expressing doubt?
嗯，你得去问乔纳森了。据说他走过去坐在了红地毯上，对吧？是的，他确实坐了。另外，我的意思是，拉廷身高大约有27英尺高。我的意思是，拉廷是一个极其高大的人。不过我想，汤姆，对于那些不喜欢足球的人来说，1966年世界杯
Well, you'd have to ask Jonathan that. And he supposedly, he goes and sits on the red carpet, doesn't he? Yeah, he does. Also, I mean, Ratton is about 27 feet tall. I mean, Ratton is a colossal man. But I suppose, Tom, for people who don't like football, I mean, the thing is a colossal man. But I suppose, Tom, for people who don't like football, I mean, the thing about the 1966 World Cup that's
在英国已成为国家想象力的一部分，那就是它与“摇摆伦敦”（Swinging London）、摇滚的60年代、美好的夏天紧密相连。英格兰队长博比·摩尔（Bobby Moore）这个英俊的金发后卫从女王手中接过奖杯，一切都那么美好。这，A，这并不
become part of the national imagination in Britain is that it's part of swinging London, the swinging 60s, lovely summer, the England captain, Bobby Moore, this sort of handsome, blonde defender accepts the trophy from the Queen and all is right with the world. That's, A, that's not
完全准确，因为如果你看一下当时的全部新闻报道，英国经济在1966年夏天陷入了困境。所以实际上所有媒体都把这报道为：“哦，这真是一个不错的逃避现实的方式。”但基本上，足协的通讯简报自己也说：“这场胜利是掩盖这个夏天国家所面临的暗淡经济形势的少数几个亮点之一。”所以世界杯周围其实弥漫着一种国家的阴暗情绪，但在国外，所有人都认为这是一届糟糕的世界杯。是的。
quite accurate because actually, if you look at all the press coverage, the British economy had run into trouble in the summer of 1966. So everybody actually reports this as saying, oh, this is a nice bit of escapism. But basically, the FA newsletter itself said, the victory is one of the few bright spots in the somber economic situation
在阿根廷，他们把“世界杯威利”打扮成海盗的模样。打扮成海盗。又是关于海盗的梗。他们对这个乐此不疲，对吧？是的，他们乐此不疲。所以无论是“世界杯威利”还是玛格丽特·撒切尔，他们都把他们打扮成海盗。我们总是在扮演海盗。像海盗一样，没错。但1966年世界杯其实是一个特例，汤姆，
which faces the country this summer. So there's a kind of national gloom actually surrounding the World Cup, but also abroad, everybody thinks it's a terrible World Cup. Yeah. And in Argentina, they show World Cup Willie dressed as a pirate. Dressed as a pirate. That's stuff about piracy. They can't get enough of that, can they? No, they can't. So it's World Cup Willie and Margaret Thatcher that they dressed as pirates. We're always dressing up as pirates. As pirates, exactly. But the 1966 World Cup is actually an anomaly, Tom,
因为1966年世界杯打破了原本属于巴西统治的故事线。所以我们现在休息一下，等我们回来后，我们将聊聊巴西、贝利以及所有关于美丽足球的一切。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。
because the 1966 World Cup is a break in a story that's otherwise won a Brazilian domination. So let's take a break now, and when we come back, we will talk Brazil, Pele, and all things beautiful game. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的首选。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐产业的幕后大幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告的音频、独家番外节目以及优先购买现场门票的资格，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史其余部分》，我们正轻快地回顾世界杯的历史。多米尼克，我们已经来到了1970年，这一届在墨西哥举行。许多人说这是历届世界杯中最棒的一届。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello welcome back to The Rest Is History we are whistling our way through the World Cup. And Dominic, we have reached 1970, which is held in Mexico. Many people say it's the best World Cup of the lot.
这也是巴西队在四届世界杯中赢得的第三次冠军。是的。所以人们可能会好奇为什么我们跳过了1958年和1962年，因为我们真的想把巴西的故事放在一起来讲。巴西是一个迷人的故事。有一本关于这个主题的出色著作——我们提到了乔纳森·威尔逊，在我看来，他是足球史学界唯一真正的伟大对手，一个名叫大卫·戈德布拉特（David Goldblatt）的人，他写了一本名为《足球国度》（Football Nation）的精彩书籍，讲述了巴西以及足球在巴西历史上的重要性。
And it's the third World Cup in four to be won by Brazil. Yes. So people may be wondering why we skipped over 1958 and 1962, because we really wanted to do Brazil all in one go. And Brazil is a fascinating story. There's a brilliant book on this by, we mentioned Jonathan Wilson, to my mind, his only great rival as the greatest historian of football, a man called David Goldblatt, who's written a wonderful book called Football Nation about Brazil and football's importance
他在开篇指出，巴西是地球上第五大国家。从许多标准来看，它是一个大国，但它没有产生任何真正伟大的艺术、科学或文学来与世界上其他国家的顶级水平相提并论。它真正闻名于世的唯一一件事——这并不是说它没有出过优秀的作家或艺术家——但它真正闻名于世的唯一一件事就是它的足球。足球已经成为凝聚国家的纽带，也是巴西向世界展示自己的方式。
in the history of Brazil. And he points out at the beginning, Brazil is the fifth largest nation on earth. So it's by many measures a great power, but it has produced no real great art or science or literature to stand comparison with the very best of other countries. The one thing it is actually famous for, that's not to say it hasn't published good writers or good artists, but the one thing it's really famous for is its football. And football has become the unifying force and the way that Brazil presents itself to the world.
他有一个非常有趣的理论，认为使巴西足球独一无二的因素之一正是巴西的不平等。所以他说，不平等带给你的是一个非常贫困的下层阶级。也就是那些在街头巷尾踢大量足球、渴望通过足球来改善自己生活的人。所以这就是人才库，如果你愿意这么称呼的话，那些可能本会从事其他行业、但实际上除了足球一无所有的人。但同时，不平等也为你创造了巨大的财富中心，能够调动这条生产线并让其运转起来。
He has a really interesting theory that one of the things that has made Brazilian football unique is the inequality of Brazil. So he says, what the inequality gives you, it gives you a very poor underclass. So the kind of people who actually grow up
换句话说，这种不平等实际上以一种奇特的方式对巴西有利。它成为了凝聚这个在地域、经济以及种族上都极其分裂的国家的纽带。但在英国的刻板印象中，这一切都只是天生的天赋，就像是从街头自然流露出来的一样，诸如此类。但实际上，在1970年，我的意思是，他们真的为之进行了非常非常刻苦的训练，对吧？他们甚至把人派到美国宇航局（NASA）去研究宇航员是如何为登月做准备的。所以，汤姆，如果要回溯到1958年——他们第一次夺冠的那一年，情况甚至在那时就已经如此了。
playing a lot of football in the streets and whatnot and are desperate to improve themselves through football. So that's the pool of talent, if you like, people who might otherwise go into other walks of life, but actually football is all they have. But the inequality also gives you immense centres of wealth who can mobilise that production line and get it running.
所以在1958年，整个国家队的队员都被送到里约最好的医院进行体检。他们发现——回到关于不平等的问题上来——几乎所有队员体内都有肠道寄生虫。有些人甚至患有梅毒。他们从球员嘴里拔掉了300颗蛀牙，噢，因为牙齿都烂了。体内有多少条肠道寄生虫呢？成百上千，绝对是成百上千，盘绕翻滚着。好吧，你不需要描述得那么……所以巴西在20世纪50年代末是一个真正试图把自己包装成现代化巅峰的国家。
So in other words, the inequality actually, in a weird way, works in Brazil's favor. It becomes the thing that unites this very regionally, economically, and of course, racially disparate country. But the stereotype in England is that it's all natural flair, that it just flows off the streets, all that kind of stuff. But actually, in 1970, I mean, they've really, really trained hard for it, haven't they? They've gone on, they've got kind of, they send people off to NASA to study how astronauts are prepared for the moon landing. So that, Tom, to go back to backtrack to 1958, the first of their wins, that was true even then.
他们有一位总统叫儒塞利诺·库比契克（Juscelino Kubitschek）。他承诺，在五年内，他们将取得相当于50年的发展进步。所以正是在这个时候他们在建设巴西利亚。正是在这个时候他们在搞各种基础设施建设。伟大的现代主义首都。伟大的现代主义者。而这支足球队则被视为现代主义的另一个象征。
So in 1958, the entire squad are sent for medicals at the best hospitals in Rio. And they find, I mean, this thing about the inequality, they find that almost all the squad have intestinal parasites. Some of them have syphilis. They extract 300 teeth from the players mouths oh uh because they're rotted there how many intestinal worms do they hundreds absolutely hundreds coiling and rolling okay you don't need to really um so brazil is a country that in the late 1950s is really trying to sell itself as the acme of
所以在1958年，整个球队被派往里约最好的医院进行体检。他们发现——我是说，关于这种不平等现象——他们发现几乎所有队员都有肠道寄生虫。有些人患有梅毒。他们从球员嘴里拔出了300颗牙齿，哦，因为牙齿都烂了，还有多少肠道寄生虫呢？成百上千，绝对是成百上千条，盘绕蠕动着。好吧，你不需要真的……嗯，所以巴西这个国家在20世纪50年代末期，真的正试图把自己标榜为……
modernity they have a president called ususelino Kubitschek. He has promised that in five years, they will have 50 years of progress. So this is when they're building Brasilia. This is when they are doing all this infrastructure. Great modernist capital. Great modernist. And the football team is seen as another emblem of modernism.
现代性的巅峰。他们有一位总统叫儒塞利诺·库比契克。他曾承诺，在五年内实现五十年的发展。所以，这就是他们建造巴西利亚的时候。这也是他们大搞基础设施建设的时候。伟大的现代主义首都。伟大的现代主义者。而这支足球队被视为现代主义的另一个象征。
And of course, the player who becomes identified with that is Pelé, who we mentioned at the end of the last uh podcast so he is he's from a very very poor background as a boy he'd worked as a servant in a tea shop to make money uh he's of course black he plays for a team called Santos in the the town of Santos which is the port city of Sao Paulo, which is booming in the 1950s and 60s. The fact that he is black really matters because this is part of, Brazil is trying to sort of rebrand itself as a, not as a white nation that held slaves. It's a rainbow nation. Exactly.
当然，与此紧密联系在一起的球员就是贝利，我们在上集播客的最后提到了他，所以他出身非常非常贫穷，小时候曾在茶馆里当过仆人赚钱，呃，他当然是黑人，他效力于圣多士队，这支球队位于圣保罗的港口城市圣多士，在20世纪50和60年代，这座城市正在蓬勃发展。他是个黑人这件事其实非常重要，因为这是巴西试图重塑自己形象的一部分，不再把自己定义为一个蓄奴的白人国家。而是一个彩虹之国。没错。
It's a multiracial nation. So previously there had been black players. Back in the 1920s, there'd been a player called Friedenreich who they called the black pearl but in those days the black players had whitened their faces with flour and had straightened their hair before matches I mean extraordinary to think of them going to all this effort before the games well but then when you look at at the obloquy that gets visited on the the three black players that that lose to Uruguay yeah 1950. I mean, it's not surprising. Yeah. So Pelé, they embraced Pelé in the 1960s. Pelé had been, because he was only 17 when they won the World Cup in 1958. So Pelé is projected around the world as this sort of
这是一个多元种族国家。所以此前曾有过黑人球员。早在20世纪20年代，曾有过一个叫弗里登赖克的球员，他们称他为黑珍珠，但在那个年代，黑人球员在比赛前会在脸上涂满面粉来美白，还要把头发烫直，我是说，想象他们在比赛前做这一切努力，真是不可思议，不过当你看到那些在1950年输给乌拉圭的三名黑人球员所遭受的恶毒辱骂时，嗯。我是说，这也不足为奇。嗯。所以贝利，他们在20世纪60年代接纳了贝利。贝利曾是，因为他们在1958年赢得世界杯时他才17岁。所以贝利被作为这样一种形象推向全世界
tremendous celebrity and this symbol of how great Brazil is now. Unfortunately, there is a problem. And the problem is that before the 1970 World Cup, so in 1964, Kubitschek's successor, a man called João Goulart, had been toppled by an army coup with American support. Basically, all that spending on infrastructure and on Brazil had seen inflation run completely out of control. The currency had plummeted. The economy had started to fall apart. The army step in. And over time in the 1960s, that army dictatorship becomes ever more repressive.
巨大的名人和巴西如今有多么伟大的象征。不幸的是，出了个问题。问题在于，在1970年世界杯之前，也就是在1964年，库比契克的继任者、一个名叫若昂·古拉特的男子，在美国的支持下被一场军事政变推翻了。基本上，在基础设施和巴西身上的大量支出导致通货膨胀彻底失控。货币暴跌。经济开始崩溃。军方介入了。而在20世纪60年代的岁月里，这个军事独裁政权变得越来越专制。
And there's a guy called General Medici who becomes the third. I like to think of him as General Medici. I thought you would. I thought you would. Well, a great patron of beauty. He's not a terribly good guy, Tom, I think it's fair to say. No, I know you would. I thought you would. Well, a great patron of beauty. He's not a terribly good guy, Tom, I think it's fair to say. No, I know he is. I know.
有个叫梅迪奇将军的人成为了第三位。我喜欢把他叫做梅迪奇将军。我就知道你会这么想。我就知道你会。嗯，一个伟大的艺术赞助人。他可不是个什么好东西，汤姆，我觉得这么说很公平。不，我知道你会。我就知道你会。嗯，一个伟大的艺术赞助人。他可不是个什么好东西，汤姆，我觉得这么说很公平。不，我知道他是。我知道。
So there's a lot. But he is absolutely, I mean, he is using the Brazil football team to brand his regime. He is, absolutely. So he's your classic South American guy, dark glasses, torture, repression, censorship. As you say, football, they really pump up this nationalism, and football is the emblem of that.
所以有很多。但他的确，我是说，他正在利用巴西足球队来为他的政权做宣传。他确实是的。所以他就是你典型的南美硬汉，戴着墨镜，施用酷刑、镇压、进行审查。正如你所说，足球，他们极力煽动这种民族主义，而足球就是这种民族主义的象征。
And what's really interesting about that is that has resonances that endure for decades. So anybody who's followed Brazil's presidential election this year very closely might have noticed that um ex-president bolsonaro and his supporters very often wore yellow brazilian team shirts and that that shirt which around the world is seen as the great symbol of brazil that is because become a symbol of bolsonaro and bolsonaro ism and a lot of the the brazilian football team are out and proud Bolsonaro fans. Absolutely.
而其中真正有趣的是，这种影响持续了几十年。所以任何密切关注今年巴西总统大选的人可能都会注意到，呃，前总统博索纳罗和他的支持者经常穿着黄色的巴西国家队球衣，而那件在全世界看来都是巴西伟大象征的球衣，已经变成了博索纳罗和博索纳罗主义的象征，而且巴西国家队的好多球员都是公开且坚定的博索纳罗粉丝。没错。
So some of the best-known players, so the best-known player of all, Neymar, who plays for Paris Saint-Germain, one of the best-known players in the world, he is a very vocal Bolsonaro supporter. Thiago Silva, who is a former Brazilian captain, plays for Chelsea, also a Bolsonaro supporter. And that often makes people raise their eyebrows
所以一些最知名的球员，比如最知名的球员内马尔，他效力于巴黎圣日耳曼，是世界上最知名的球员之一，他是一个非常直言不讳的博索纳罗支持者。蒂亚戈·席尔瓦，前巴西队队长，效力于切尔西，也是博索纳罗的支持者。这常常让人挑起眉毛
because they say, these people are from very poor backgrounds. How is it they support Bolsonaro? They're also very rich. It's because they're very rich. They're very rich. Footballers often have been seen as conservative because they have made it, they are aspirational, they believe in talent and all this sort of stuff.
因为他们会说，这些人出身非常贫穷。他们怎么会支持博索纳罗呢？他们也很有钱。这是因为他们很有钱。他们很有钱。足球运动员常常被视为保守派，因为他们成功了，他们有追求成功的野心，他们信仰天赋以及诸如此类的一切。
So you can sort of see why some of them might be drawn to a kind of right-wing ideology. And it's fascinating that Lula's supporters tend to wear the blue away shirt of Brazil and Bolsonaro's the yellow. So in 1970, the manager had been a communist, hadn't he? Charles Saldanha, yeah. So the kind of the infrastructure, the patronage is, well, I mean, call it right wing. I mean, it's verging on the fascists. Yes.
所以你可以理解为什么他们中的一些人可能会被某种右翼意识形态所吸引。而且很有趣的是，卢拉的支持者往往穿着巴西队的蓝色客场球衣，而博索纳罗的支持者则穿着黄色。所以在1970年，主教练曾是个共产主义者，对吧？萨尔达尼亚，是的。所以某种程度上，基础设施、政治庇护是，好吧，我是说，称之为右翼。我的意思是，这简直濒临法西斯了。是的。
But the manager is communist. And that is expressive of the tensions in Brazil that we see in the recent election. But they boot him out, Tom. They boot him out before the tournament. So Saldanha. But also because he wouldn't buy, he wouldn't choose. The general's favourite players. The general's favourite players, would he?
但主教练是个共产主义者。这恰恰表达了我们在最近这次大选中看到的巴西内部的紧张关系。但他们把他赶走了，汤姆。他们在锦标赛开始前把他赶走了。也就是萨尔达尼亚。但也是因为他不愿意收买，不愿意挑选。将军最喜欢的球员。将军最喜欢的球员，对吧？
That's right. So he had to be sacked well he he gets increasing criticism um which must have been fermented by the regime and eventually the manager saldania goes to meet a journalist but he takes a gun with him presumably to shoot the journalist at that point they sack him and they bring in an ex-player called mario zagalo who who basically will not rock the boat. Will do what? Exactly. And then the extraordinary thing. So in 1970, so Brazil have already won the World Cup twice. In 1970, the regime built a communications infrastructure for the first time so that everybody in the entire country can watch the matches on television. And this is, the World Cup is held in Mexico,
没错。所以他不得不被解雇，呃，他受到的批评越来越多，这肯定是政权在幕后煽动的，最终主教练萨尔达尼亚去和一个记者会面，但他随身带了一支枪，大概是想枪杀那个记者，就在那个时候，他们解雇了他，并请来了一位名叫马里奥·扎加洛的前球员，他基本上不会兴风作浪。会怎么做？没错。然后是不可思议的事情。所以在1970年，巴西已经赢过两次世界杯了。在1970年，政权首次建设了通信基础设施，以便全国的每个人都能够在电视上观看比赛。这是，世界杯在墨西哥举行，
and this is the first World Cup to be televised in color. It's one reason why the team of Pelé is so embedded in the world. It's the kind of brightness, and the light is so vivid, isn't it? Exactly, it is. Because it has that kind of early colour TV, lurid kind of... Technicolour kind of quality to it. Exactly, and Brazil playing in these sort of bright yellow shirts. And they storm through the tournament.
这也是第一届有彩色电视转播的世界杯。这也是贝利的球队如此深入人心的一个原因。那种明亮感，光线是如此生动，对吧？没错，确实如此。因为它具有那种早期彩色电视机、带点刺眼的……特艺七彩般的质感。没错，而且巴西穿着这种亮黄色的球衣踢球。他们一路势如破竹地杀入决赛。
They play a series of sort of legendary games. They beat England. They beat Uruguay, the old enemy, in the semifinals. And then they thrash Italy 4-1 in the final, scoring these beautiful goals. I mean, the Jornal do Brasil says after 1970, Brazil's victory with the ball compares with the conquest of the moon by the Americans.
他们踢了一系列堪称传奇的比赛。他们击败了英格兰。他们在半决赛中击败了老对手乌拉圭。然后在决赛中以4比1痛击意大利，打进了一些如此精彩的进球。我是说，《巴西日报》在1970年之后说，巴西用足球取得的胜利，可以与美国人征服月球相提并论。
So the Brazilians, I mean, we think we're bad in England at these. I mean, they compared their defeat to Hiroshima. To Hiroshima. Now they're comparing it to the moon landings. Medici, the dictator,
所以巴西人，我是说，我们总觉得自己英格兰在这些事上很糟糕。我是说，他们把失败比作广岛。比作广岛。现在他们把它比作登月。独裁者梅迪奇，
absolutely revels in this. He says, our players won because of their, it was a victory won in the brotherhood of good sportsmanship with the rise of faith in our fight for national development above all our players won because they know how to play for the collective good and the problem i suppose you have is that pele who is such a sentimental
对此简直欣喜若狂。他说，我们的球员获胜是因为他们的，这是一场在体育道德的兄弟情谊中赢得的胜利，伴随着对我们争取国家发展斗争的坚定信念，最重要的是，我们的球员获胜是因为他们懂得为了集体利益而战，我想你遇到的问题是，贝利这样一个在全世界
favorite around the world he is undoubtedly complicit to some degree with the regime well or he just he's oblivious do you think i don't know i mean this is a hard one tom i mean do we how do you resolve that is he is he complicit or is he is there such a thing as being oblivious well he is a genius whose focus is football and he is so i guess so idolized that he comes to see the world through you know in pelle-ish terms yeah if such a word um but pelle is not a fool so pelle uh in the 1960s the the contrast had been with another player called garincha who was a another brilliantly talented player pelle had been the model professional and garincha had been the wayward one. So Pelé was aspirational. He was respectable. He had tried to make money. Garincha had just been sort of hanging around in pubs and- Being a lad.
备受喜爱的传奇人物，他无疑在某种程度上与这个政权同流合污了。好吧，或者他只是茫然无知呢？你觉得呢？我不知道，汤姆，这很难说，我是说，我们该如何解决这个问题？他是同流合污了，还是真的存在“无知”这种说法？好吧，他是一个将全部焦点都放在足球上的天才，他被如此这般地奉若神明，以至于他开始通过（你知道的）贝利式的视角来看待世界，是的，如果能这么说的话……但贝利可不是傻瓜。所以贝利，在20世纪60年代，人们曾把他与另一位名叫加林查的球员进行对比，加林查是另一位才华横溢的球员。贝利是模范职业球员，而加林查则是特立独行的那个。所以贝利有追求。他体面。他一直在努力赚钱。加林查只是在酒吧里鬼混，然后——就是个浪荡子。
Being a lad, exactly. And people had sort of held up, columnists had held up Pelé and said, this is the model of what Brazil should be. And I think Pelé is not entirely naive. I don't want to think that. Pelé does defend the dictatorship. So when he went to Uruguay in 1972, he said, I don't want to know this. I'm going to tell you, because you need to know.
就是个浪荡子，没错。人们曾把贝利捧上神坛，专栏作家们曾把贝利树为典范，说这才是巴西应该有的样子。而且我认为贝利并不是完全天真。我可不想这么想。贝利确实为独裁政权辩护过。所以当他在1972年去乌拉圭时，他说，我不想知道这些。我要告诉你，因为你需要知道。
He said there is no dictatorship in Brazil. Brazil is a liberal country, a land of happiness. Our leaders know what is best for us, and they govern us with tolerance and patriotism. Let's move on. Okay, you've made your point. But actually, Tom, you know what? I'm not going to stamp on Pele, because as people often say, what do you do in those circumstances? It's very easy to say, oh, you should join the resistance.
他说巴西没有独裁统治。巴西是一个自由的国家，是幸福的土地。我们的领导人最清楚什么对我们最好，他们以宽容和爱国精神统治着我们。我们继续吧。好吧，你已经表明你的观点了。但事实上，汤姆，你知道吗？我不会去贬低贝利，因为正如人们常说的那样，在那种情况下你能怎么做？说“哦，你应该加入抵抗运动”可真是太容易了。
Oh, you should, you know, had he spoken, his life would have changed immeasurably had he spoken out against the regime. I mean, this is absolutely the key to the fascination of the World Cup and the moral ambivalences that surround it that we see in Qatar at the moment.
哦，你应该，你知道的，如果他公开发声，如果他公开反对这个政权，他的人生将发生无法估量的改变。我是说，这绝对是世界杯的魅力所在，以及围绕着它的道德矛盾，我们在卡塔尔也看到了这一点。
Yeah. That's so much, it's so compelling. It's so gripping. There's so much kind of, well, I mean, it's famously beautiful. It's the word that's associated with Palace football. The excitement of it is kind of so interfused with wealth, with oppression, with, you know, in the case of Argentina and Brazil in the 60s and 70s with incredibly oppressive dictatorships, that it becomes very difficult to separate them, don't they? So Brazil's triumph in 70, I guess, is also the triumph of the regime. Which lasts for another 15 years.
是的。太吸引人了。太扣人心弦了。有太多这种，好吧，我的意思是，它以美闻名。这是与贝利的足球联系在一起的词。那种兴奋感与财富、压迫感交织在一起，你知道的，就60和70年代的阿根廷和巴西而言，还伴随着极其残酷的独裁政权，以至于很难将它们分开，对吧？所以巴西在70年的胜利，我想，也是该政权的胜利。这将持续另外15年。
As will be the case in Argentina in 1978. Anyway, so I think that is a point well made. You just didn't want to hear it. No, I didn't really want to hear it. No, I don't really want to hear it. Well, come on, let's talk about the Dutch. You love the Dutch. Cleanse your mind by talking about You just didn't want to hear it. No, I didn't really want to hear it. No, I don't really want to hear it. Well, come on, let's talk about the Dutch. You love the Dutch. Cleanse your mind by talking about the Dutch. So 1974 in West Germany, which is another classic.
正如1978年的阿根廷那样。不管怎样，我觉得这个观点提得很好。你只是不想听罢了。不，我真的不想听。不，我真的不想听。好吧，来吧，我们聊聊荷兰人吧。你很喜欢荷兰人。通过聊聊荷兰人来净化一下你的心灵吧。你只是不想听罢了。不，我真的不想听。不，我真的不想听。好吧，来吧，我们聊聊荷兰人吧。你很喜欢荷兰人。通过聊聊荷兰人来净化一下心灵。所以在1974年的西德，这也是一场经典之战。
Yeah. So, yes, so total football, all that kind of thing. So total football for people who don't like football. So it's the Dutch who've never been a power before. They pitch up in 1974 with this very exciting brand of football where they're all swapping positions and playing a very fluid game and so the dutch is sort of the 60s in human form aren't they i think that's what people sort of say about the dutch they all have long hair they're very free love they all look very cool hanging out at saunas yeah and yeah with the
是的。所以，是的，全攻全守，诸如此类的事情。所以对于不喜欢足球的人来说，什么是全攻全守？这就是以前从未成为强队的荷兰人。他们在1974年带着这种令人兴奋的足球风格登场，队员们不断换位，踢着一种极具流动性的比赛，所以荷兰人某种程度上就是60年代的人形化身，对吧？我想这正是人们对荷兰人的评价，他们都留着长发，崇尚自由恋爱，在桑拿房里闲逛时看起来都酷极了，而且，是的，跟
late with the ladies a brilliant writer about dutch football called david winner uh wrote a book called brilliant orange uh he says holland's 1974 team is somehow the summer of love sergeant pepper altamont and the death of john lennon all in one four-week period because of the trajectory of what happens to them yes because they're brilliant they're everyone's favorite to win uh and inevitably they lose to germany to west germany in the uh in the in the final yeah and we should say emphasize it is west germany of course because this is the world cup where west germany play east germany and actually lose they do but then come back to win the whole tournament and they're in their on their native soil exactly um and just before we come to the final um the other um kind of famous incident that happens in the 74 World Cup is the Zaire qualify.
美女们在一起。一位极具才华的荷兰足球作家大卫·温纳曾写过一本名为《灿烂的橙色》的书，他写道：“荷兰1974年的球队在某种程度上是爱之夏、佩珀军士、阿尔塔蒙特音乐节以及约翰·列侬之死的结合体，这一切都发生在短短四周之内，”因为他们命运的轨迹就是如此，是的，因为他们表现极其出色，是所有人眼中夺冠的大热门，而不可避免的是，他们在决赛中输给了德国，输给了西德队。是的，我们应该强调，这当然是西德，因为这是西德对阵东德的世界杯，而且西德实际上还输了，但随后他们卷土重来，赢得了整场比赛的冠军，而且是在他们自己的主场。没错，呃，就在我们谈到决赛之前，呃，74年世界杯上发生另一件呃所谓的著名事件是扎伊尔获得了参赛资格。
Zaire, former Belgian Congo, then Congo, under another dictator, a far more flamboyant one than the than the south american variety uh mabutu and mabutu is very very keen that zaire um win glory for zaire and indeed for africa yes and they go there and they lose nine nil to yugoslavia they also lose to scotland i mean that takes some doing yeah okay but they lose nine nil to yugoslavia. And does Mobutu respond well to this? No, he doesn't. So he says, you have all brought shame on the country of Zaire. You are scum and sons of whores. Wow.
扎伊尔，前比利时刚果，后来的刚果，在另一个独裁者的统治下，比南美洲的那种独裁者要浮夸得多，也就是蒙博托，而蒙博托非常非常渴望扎伊尔能为扎伊尔甚至为非洲赢得荣耀，是的，他们去了那里，结果以0比9输给了南斯拉夫，他们还输给了苏格兰，我是说，这可真不容易做到，好吧，但他们确实0比9输给了南斯拉夫。那么蒙博托对此反应如何呢？不，他反应很差。所以他说，你们所有人都给扎伊尔国家带来了耻辱。你们是一群渣滓和婊子的儿子。哇。
So again, people think that criticism of the England team is brutal. I mean, you can't imagine Rishi Sunak saying that when Harry Kane gets dumped out. There's a very famous incident. So in their final match, they are told by Mobutu's men, if they lose by four goals or more. Three goals, I think. No, if they lose by four goals, they will not be allowed to return to Zaire or their family. I thought they were going to be killed.
所以同样地，人们认为对英格兰队的批评已经够残酷了。我是说，你简直无法想象里希·苏纳克在哈里·凯恩被淘汰时会说出这种话。这里有一个非常著名的事件。所以在他们的最后一场比赛中，他们被蒙博托的手下告知，如果他们输掉四个球或更多。三个球，我想。不，如果他们输掉四个球，他们将不准返回扎伊尔，他们的家人也是。我还以为他们会被杀呢。
Or they will be killed, exactly. So they actually lose 3-0. But very late in the match, the Brazilians have a free kick, and they're about to take the free kick when one of the Zairean players, a man called Mwepu Olunga, he just suddenly races down the field and boots the ball wildly out of the stadium. And in the commentary, if you watch that, the BBC commentator says,
或者他们会被杀，没错。所以他们实际上以0比3落败。但在比赛快结束时，巴西人获得了一个任意球，正当他们准备主罚时，其中一名扎伊尔球员，一个叫姆韦普·伊伦加的男子，突然沿着球场飞奔，一脚把球狠狠地踢出了球场。如果你看当时的比赛转播，BBC的解说员说，
a bizarre moment of African innocence. So that's how people kind of perceive it. They don't even know the rules. But actually the truth is they're just desperate to waste time. Yeah. And sort of spoil the match. And they're 2-0 down at that point. They lose 3-0, but that's enough.
非洲人纯真而诡异的一幕。这就是人们对它的看法。他们甚至不懂规则。但事实是他们只是迫不及待地想要拖延时间。是的。以此来搅乱比赛。当时他们已经以0比2落后了。他们最终以0比3输了，但这已经足够了。
They don't die. Anyway, so that's, I mean, that's again a kind of reminder of kind of the brutal circumstances under which people play. So Haiti were playing as well in that. They were. That's their only World Cup participation. So when we talked about, what's his name? Guy Jans, the guy. Gaitans, yeah. Gaitans. So he had subsequently vanished in Haiti under Papadoc Duvalier. And the Duvalier's regime is still in place in 74 when Haiti goes. So some very unsavory figures. I mean, on that African thing, Dom, our producer,
他们没有死。不管怎样，这再次提醒了人们踢球时所处的残酷环境。所以海地当时也在参加比赛。他们确实在。那是他们唯一一次参加世界杯。所以当我们谈到，叫什么来名字？盖·让，那个人。盖唐，是的。盖唐。他后来在海地大独裁者巴巴多克·杜瓦利埃统治下神秘失踪了。而当海地去参赛时，杜瓦利埃政权在74年依然稳固。所以有一些非常声名狼藉的人物。说到那个非洲的话题，多姆，我们的制作人，
was just saying it's actually quite sad. It put back the perception of African football decades. And he's right, actually, because even the 1990s. So I remember in the 1990s, a British TV program called Fantasy Football, David Baddiel and Frank Skinner, they actually got this guy, what was his name? Elunga. Elunga, they got Elunga, they flew him over
刚刚说这其实挺让人难过的。这让人们对非洲足球的看法倒退了几十年。他其实说得对，甚至到了20世纪90年代。所以我记得在20世纪90年代，有一个英国电视节目叫《梦幻足球》，大卫·巴狄尔和弗兰克·斯金纳，他们真的把这家伙，他叫什么名字？伊伦加。伊伦加，他们把伊伦加找来，把他用飞机接过来
to reproduce this moment of him booting the ball away ludicrously. And everyone thought it was hilarious and sort of laughed at him. And actually, the truth of the matter is, there's a pretty dark story behind it. Yeah, I mean, he was... and sort of laughed at him. And, you know, and actually the truth of the matter is there's a pretty dark story behind it. Yeah, I mean, he was... In fear of his life. Literally in fear of his life. And all his teammates.
重现他荒谬地将球踢飞的那一刻。每个人都觉得这滑稽极了，甚至都在嘲笑他。但事实上，这背后的故事其实相当黑暗。是的，我的意思是，他当时……甚至都在嘲笑他。而且，你知道，事实的真相是，这背后有一个相当黑暗的故事。是的，我的意思是，他当时……生命受到威胁。字面意义上的生命受到威胁。他的所有队友也是。
Yeah. He was very much taking a bullet for the team. But to return... Or not. Or not. But to return to the Dutch. So the Dutch get to the final and they're going to play the Germans. The Dutch are outraged because the German newspaper, BILT,
是的。他真的是在为球队挡子弹。但回到……或者说没有。或者说没有。但回到荷兰人这里。所以荷兰人杀入了决赛，他们将迎战德国人。荷兰人对此愤怒不已，因为德国的《图片报》
has been reporting stories about their... What described that shenanigans they've been having naked pool parties with local girls behind their wife's back the germans report this and the dutch are absolutely furious now the dutch at least some of them it's very clear we talked at the right at the beginning about the shadow of the second world war that shadow has not gone away so afterwards a lot of people talked about the how they hated the germans they were determined to beat them i mean the interesting thing is that quite a lot of the players weren't even born at the time of the second world war but one of them definitely was and that's a man called vim van hannigan who was a great sort of he was
一直在报道关于他们的……也就是他们背着妻子与当地女孩在泳池举行裸体派对的荒唐事。德国人报道了这些，荷兰人彻底被激怒了。现在荷兰人，至少他们中的一些人，很明显，我们在最开始谈到过第二次世界大战的阴影，那个阴影并未消散。所以在赛后，很多人谈到他们有多么痛恨德国人，他们决心要击败他们。有趣的是，很多球员在二战时甚至还没出生，但其中一人绝对出生了，他叫维姆·范哈内亨，他是一个伟大的，可以说他是
one of the great midfield generals of that dutch team um he'd been born in 1944 and he i mean this is what he said he said i didn't give a damn about the score one there was enough as long as we could humiliate them i hate them they murdered my family my father my sister two of my brothers each time i faced germany i was filled with angst so you dig into this story van Van Haneghan was born in February 1944 in a fishing village called Breskens, which is near the Belgian border. And Breskens was at the center of a battle in 1944 called the Battle of the Scheldt, when the Allies were trying to basically break through into the Netherlands. And on the 11th of September 1944, that town, Breskens, had been carpet bombed.
那支荷兰队中伟大的中场指挥官之一，他出生于1944年，我是说他是这么说的，他说我才不在乎比分是多少，只要能羞辱他们就行。我恨他们。他们谋杀了我的家人，我的父亲、姐姐、还有两个兄弟。每次面对德国，我都充满了焦虑。所以当你深入了解这个故事，范哈内亨出生于1944年2月，在一个叫布雷斯肯斯的渔村，靠近比利时边境。布雷斯肯斯是1944年一场名为斯海尔德战役的中心，当时盟军正试图突入荷兰。1944年9月11日，布雷斯肯斯镇遭到了地毯式轰炸。
And Van Haneghan's father, his brothers, his sister, and his uncle had all been killed. 199 people, the fifth of the town's population had been killed. So you can see why he felt so strongly. But the only thing is, they'd actually been bombed by the Allies, not by the Germans. I did not know that. So he tells that story. You know, I hate the Germans I hate them because of the war
范哈内亨的父亲、兄弟、姐姐和叔叔全部遇难。199人丧生，占全镇人口的五分之一。所以你能理解为什么他的感触如此之深。但问题是，他们实际上是被盟军轰炸的，而不是德国人。我竟然不知道这件事。所以他讲述了这个故事。你知道的，我恨德国人，我因为战争而恨他们
but the tragedy of it well I mean it's a tragic story anyway but the sort of the tragic irony is that the people who had bombed them were almost certainly
但悲剧的，好吧，我的意思是，这本就是一个悲剧故事，但那种悲剧性的讽刺在于，轰炸他们的人几乎可以肯定是
the Allies who had obviously been bombing to sort of lay the groundwork for their for their sort of ground troops
盟军，他们当时显然是为了地面部队的推进而在进行轰炸铺垫。
anyway what happens is this incredible final. So the referee, Tom, you'll be delighted to hear, is an Englishman. He's a butcher from Wolverhampton called Jack Taylor, often regarded as the greatest referee of all time, certainly by me.
不管怎样，接下来发生了这场不可思议的决赛。汤姆，你一定会很高兴听到，裁判是个英国人。他是来自沃尔夫汉普顿的屠夫，名叫杰克·泰勒，通常被认为是史上最伟大的裁判，至少在我看来是这样。
After a minute, he gives the Dutch a penalty. The Germans haven't even touched the ball. And it gets slotted in. And the German captain, do you want to talk about him? Uh, Beckenbauer who comes to be given the name of Kaiser.
开场仅一分钟，他就判给荷兰队一个点球。德国人甚至都还没碰到球。点球稳稳罚进。德国队长，你想聊聊他吗？呃，贝肯鲍尔，后来被称为“凯撒”。
Kaiser. I mean, so is wearing the correct sportswear on his feet. Yeah. I assume for a World Cup final. Unlike Kaiser Wilhelm II before the First World War. Absolutely. Um,
凯撒。我是说，他的脚上穿着正确的运动装备吗？是的。我猜对于一场世界杯决赛来说是这样的。不像一战前的威廉二世皇帝那样。绝对的。呃，
and, and he says to the referee, doesn't he? Basically, that's very English behaviour. He says, Taylor. This is all about the war. Taylor, you are an Englishman. I mean, some people, I would take that as a tremendous compliment,
而且，他对裁判说，不是吗？基本上，那是极其英国式的行为。他说，泰勒。这整件事都跟战争有关。泰勒，你是个英国人。我是说，有些人，我会把这当作极大的赞美，
but clearly not. Well, yeah. Anyway, the Dutch then, partly because of this, who knows, because of this war stuff, because they cross about the stories about their misbehaviour and saunas. They don't press home their advantage. They just pass the ball around mocking the Germans. Yes, but isn't that the thing that they wanted to kind of show off, basically? And everybody, anyone who listens to the first half of this episode
但显然他不是。好吧，是的。不管怎样，荷兰人随后，部分是因为这个，谁知道呢，因为这些战争的恩怨，因为他们对有关自己行为不端和桑拿房的报道感到生气。他们没有乘胜追击。他们只是在传球，以此嘲笑德国人。是的，但他们不是本来就想借此炫耀一番吗？而且每个人，任何听过这集上半部分的人
knows what's going to happen. The Germans win 2-1. And the Dutch are bitter about that to this day. So years later, when they defeated the Germans in the European Championships, one of their players mimed wiping his bottom on a German player's shirt in front of all the Dutch fans. The fans flew banners comparing German players to Hitler. There were all kinds of bitterness and bad blood.
都知道会发生什么。德国人以2比1获胜。直到今天，荷兰人对此依然耿耿于怀。所以多年后，当他们在欧洲杯上击败德国人时，其中一名球员当着所有荷兰球迷的面，做出了假装用德国球员的球衣擦屁股的动作。球迷们打出了把德国球员比作希特勒的横幅。到处都是怨恨和积怨。
Right. So they lose that, but they have a shot at redemption four years later, where the World Cup is being held in Argentina. And this is the most extraordinary story, probably of all the stories, isn't it? The Argentine hunter in the World Cup. It really is. Yes. So all the World Cups that we've discussed with the backdrop of dictators using it to sports wash, to promote their regimes, Argentina in 1978 is the one that is most often compared to the Berlin Olympics. It's the most overt. So the World Cup had been awarded to Argentina in 1966 at a point when they've already had a military coup, but the regime
好吧。所以他们输了，但在四年后的世界杯上，他们迎来了复仇的机会，那一年的世界杯在阿根廷举行。这可能是所有故事中最不可思议的故事了，对吧？世界杯上的阿根廷军政府。确实如此。是的。所以我们讨论过的所有以独裁者利用体育洗白、宣传政权为背景的世界杯中，1978年的阿根廷是最常被拿来与柏林奥运会相提并论的一届。它是最公开的。所以世界杯是在1966年授予阿根廷的，当时他们已经发生了一场军事政变，但这个政权
is not, it's authoritarian, but it's not utterly horrific. Then they got democracy back in 1973, and Juan Perón, the great populist of the- Who doesn't like football. Who doesn't like football, of the post-World War II era, he had come back at the age of 187 to become president of Argentina. So they created a logo based on Perón's salute. He had this salute where he put both hands above his head. And they made the logo for the World Cup in an emulation of Perón's salute. Perón, unfortunately, dies in July 1974. And he's succeeded by his wife isabelita who's she's a sort of nightclub performer or
并不是，它是威权主义的，但并不是极端恐怖的。然后他们在1973年恢复了民主，胡安·佩隆，这位伟大的民粹主义者——不喜欢足球。不喜欢足球，战后时代的代表，他以187岁（译者注：原文为主持人夸张调侃）的高龄回归并成为了阿根廷总统。所以他们以佩隆的敬礼为原型设计了一个标志。他有一种将双臂高举过头顶的敬礼姿势。他们把世界杯的标志设计成了效仿佩隆敬礼的样式。不幸的是，佩隆于1974年7月逝世。接替他的是他的妻子伊莎贝利塔，她大概是个夜总会歌女或
something who's about 80 years younger than him perron he had a thing for night he did indeed and uh she presides over complete and utter chaos so there's hundreds and hundreds of bombings and murders there's inflation at a gazillion percent uh the currency collapses uh i mean there's a point at which jonathan wilson says in his history of argentina a bomb was going off in buenos aires on average every three hours and there was a political assassination every five hours so in march 1976 it's a coup the army kick out isabelita and the head of the army who's a man called j Rafael Videla he becomes president and this is not just your bog standard military authoritarian regime kind of chucking people out of helicopters poets being electrocuted this is absolutely with concrete on their feet being chucked into rivers exactly
什么之类的人，比佩隆年轻大约80岁。佩隆确实好这一口，没错，她上台后引起了彻底的混乱。所以有成百上千起爆炸和谋杀，通货膨胀率达到了天文数字，货币崩盘了，我是说，正如乔纳森·威尔逊在阿根廷历史书中写的那样，布宜诺斯艾利斯平均每三小时就会发生一起爆炸，每五小时就会发生一次政治暗杀。所以在1976年3月，发生了政变，军方赶走了伊莎贝利塔，陆军司令、一个叫豪尔赫·拉斐尔·魏地拉的人成为了总统。这可不仅仅是你那种把人从直升机上扔下去、让诗人们遭受电击的标准的军事威权政权，这绝对是脚上灌着水泥被扔进河里的那种
yeah it's horrendous so maybe that I mean who knows how many people died or or are disappeared as the as the saying goes so we're probably the sort So the most common figure you see is 30,000 people of their own citizens. So the hunter, as they're called, are very, very keen on the World Cup. They invest about 10% of the national budget. So that's $700 million in building new stadiums, in new infrastructure. They also redevelop. I mean, this is an amazing thing. I mean, this is infrastructure. They also redeveloped. I mean, this is an amazing thing. I mean, this is actually not unheard of at all.
是的，太可怕了。所以，谁知道有多少人死去，或者像俗话说的“被失踪”了呢？所以最常见的数字，你看到的通常是3万名自己的公民。所以军政府，正如他们被称为的那样，对世界杯非常非常热衷。他们投入了大约10%的国家预算。也就是7亿美元用于建设新体育场和新的基础设施。他们还重建了。我是说，这太惊人了。我是说，这是基础设施。他们还重建了。我是说，这太惊人了。我是说，这其实一点也不罕见。
I mean, Brazil did this in 2014. Qatar, obviously, are no strangers to slightly dodgy infrastructure investments. In Buenos Aires, they build a massive concrete wall so that when you're driving into town, you won see you won't see the shanty towns yeah yeah you and they bus people out don't they from towns they play cities that are playing um the hosting world cup to cities that aren't it's i mean it's unbelievable the guy the guy who was organizing the tournament's killed in a car bomb because another he's a general another general fancies the corruption possibilities so general general number one is, is murdered.
我是说，巴西在2014年就这么干过。卡塔尔显然对这种稍微有点可疑的基础设施投资也不陌生。在布宜诺斯艾利斯，他们修了一堵巨大的水泥墙，这样当你开车进城时，你就看不到贫民窟了，是的，是的。而且他们把人从那些举办世界杯的城市用大巴拉到不举办世界杯的城市，这，简直难以置信。组织这届世界杯的家伙在一场汽车炸弹袭击中被炸死了，因为另一个将军也想分一杯腐败的羹，所以第一位将军被谋杀了。
And, and so, um, Amnesty International, very hostile to it. There's the, the, the, the kind of the rumbling in,
因此，国际特赦组织对此非常敌视。世界足坛及其他地方的
in world football and beyond is very analogous to what's been happening with Qatar. Yeah. Uh, as with Qatar, it doesn't actually, you know, footballers may speak out against it,
非议和骚动与卡塔尔发生的事情非常相似。是的。就像卡塔尔一样，这实际上并没有（你知道的），足球运动员可能会公开反对，
but it doesn't stop them from going. Yeah. Everybody goes. I think, well, apart from, footballers may speak out against it, but it doesn't stop them from going. Yeah, everybody goes. I think, well, apart from the West German defender, Paul Breitner. Who's a Maoist, Tom. Yes. I mean, so actually, you know that 1974 final, which is sort of Dutch kids of the 60s versus these grim, grinding Germans. That's a complete stereotype because
但这并不能阻止他们去参加。是的。所有人都去了。我想，除了西德后卫保罗·布赖特纳。他是个毛派，汤姆。是的。所以实际上，你知道1974年的那场决赛，那是60年代的荷兰小伙子们对阵那些冷酷、死板的德国人。这完全是一种刻板印象，因为
the guy who scores German is equaliser, Breitner, is an overt supporter of Mao's China. Okay, so he doesn't go, but everyone else does. And the West German World Cup had seen the real growth of commercialism, commercial sponsorship. And so Western companies have a massive, massive commercial investment in Argentina. And they're very, very, very keen that the World Cup go ahead.
为德国队攻入扳平进球的球员布赖特纳，其实是毛泽东时代的公开支持者。好吧，所以他没去，但其他人全去了。西德的世界杯见证了商业主义、商业赞助的真正增长。因此，西方公司在阿根廷有巨大无比的商业投资。他们非常非常希望世界杯能够顺利举行。
And the other person who is very, very keen that it go ahead is Dr. Henry Kissinger. Yes, yeah. Kissinger loves football, to be fair to Kissinger. Kissinger had loved football since his days in Germany as a boy. But he also thinks that the World Cup will be great for...
另一个非常非常希望它顺利举行的人是亨利·基辛格博士。是的，是的。说句公道话，基辛格很喜欢足球。基辛格从小在德国时就喜欢足球。但他同时也认为世界杯对……
Kissinger never saw a right-wing... South American dictator. That he didn't want to support. The opening game is actually West Germany against Poland. Terrible game. Kissinger's there. Kissinger's there and he's saying this is a World Cup for peace. All that kind of stuff. Kissinger's there and he, um, Kissinger's there and he's saying this is a world cup for peace. Oh, that's nice.
基辛格从来没见过哪个右翼南美独裁者是他不想支持的。揭幕战实际上是西德对阵波兰。一场糟糕的比赛。基辛格也在场。基辛格在场，他说这是一届为了和平的世界杯。诸如此类的话。基辛格在场，他，嗯，基辛格在场，他说这是一届为了和平的世界杯。哦，那挺好的。
So, um, so, um, Argentina in, um, a very, very tricky group. So they're with France, they're with Italy, they're with Hungary. And after the Hungary match, Argentina just scraped through 2-1. Uh, one of the, uh, one of the Junta, um, warns one of the argentine team that you better get out of this or else it will literally be a group of death it's been told that yeah i mean this podcast has been full of people making threats to players or you know and this is also another one where so so all the rumors that we've been talking about throughout this series so very strong rumors that the argentine team in the match against fr France are on amphetamines.
所以，呃，所以，阿根廷分在一个非常非常棘手的小组。他们和法国、意大利、匈牙利分在了一组。在对阵匈牙利的比赛之后，阿根廷以2比1险胜。军政府的其中一人，警告了阿根廷队的一名成员，说你们最好从这里突围，否则这真的会变成死亡之组。他们被这么告知了。我是说，这期播客充满了对球员的威胁，你知道的，这也是另一次。所以，我们在整个系列中谈论的所有传闻——关于阿根廷队在对阵法国队的比赛中服用了兴奋剂的强烈传闻。
And then they get through the group of death and they have to play Peru, don't they? And all kinds of stories around this. So it's one of these weird structures that you sometimes have in the World Cup where you get through the group and you have to then go into another group. They're in a group with Brazil and Peru.
然后他们通过了死亡之组，必须对阵秘鲁，对吧？围绕这一点有各种各样的故事。这是世界杯中有时会出现的那种奇怪赛制之一，你从小组出线后，还得进入另一个小组。他们和巴西、秘鲁分在同一个小组。
And whoever, they and Brazil are kind of level. So Argentina will have to beat Peru by four goals to get through to the final. So interestingly, actually, you mentioned with Brazil that their original manager, João Saldanha, had been a communist. The manager of Argentina is a former communist, Cesar Luiz Menotti. Menotti is a very bohemian figure, kind of chain-oking intellectual very gaunt isn't very gaunt exactly now his so his team he's gotten through to this what's effectively i suppose you could say a semi-final against peru which they need to win by four goals and this is the single most controversial match
无论谁，他们和巴西积分差不多。所以阿根廷必须以四个球的优势击败秘鲁才能晋级决赛。有趣的是，你之前提到巴西的原主教练若昂·萨尔达尼亚曾是一名共产主义者。阿根廷的主教练则是一位前共产主义者，塞萨尔·路易斯·梅诺蒂。梅诺蒂是一个非常具有波西米亚风格的人物，是个烟不离手的知识分子，身形非常消瘦。非常消瘦，没错。现在他的球队，他已经晋级到了这场实际上你可以说是对阵秘鲁的半决赛，他们需要净胜四球，而这是世界杯历史上
politically in the world cup's history because argent Argentina win that match 6-0. And ever since, there have been endless rumours, for quite good reasons, one of which is that shortly before the match, Fidelio, who's the head of the Argentine regime, is seen going into the Peruvian dressing room. It is said with Henry Kissinger. Yeah, well, there are three different, there are three separate, I mean, the trouble with the conspiracy theories, Tom,
政治上最具争议的一场比赛。因为阿根廷以6比0赢了那场比赛。从那以后，各种传闻就从未间断过，而且理由相当充分，其中之一就是比赛开始前不久，阿根廷政权首脑魏地拉被看到走进了秘鲁队的更衣室。据说还有亨利·基辛格。好吧，有三个不同的，有三个独立的，我是说，阴谋论的麻烦在于，汤姆，
is when they start to multiply, you think, I mean, there are too many. You could do, you could do, or you could say, well, the evidence is stacking up. So here we go. First of all, there's the claim that Videla and Kissinger visit the Peruvian dressing room. The Peruvian players tell their story or one or two of them claim that Kissinger was there.
当它们开始倍增时，你会觉得，我是说，这实在太多了。你可以，你可以，或者你可以说，证据正在堆积如山。所以，我们开始吧。首先，有这样一种说法：魏地拉和基辛格造访了秘鲁更衣室。秘鲁球员讲述了他们的故事，或者其中一两个球员声称基辛格当时在那里。
Kissinger denies it, doesn't he? Kissinger denies it, but they say that there's no deal done. So they say, we don't know why he was there. He just wished us good luck and then left. We didn't know what that meant. That's number one. Number two, which was made by the Sunday Times some years later, the Sunday Times claimed that the Argentine
基辛格否认了，对吧？基辛格否认了，但他们说并没有达成什么交易。所以他们说，我们不知道他为什么在那儿。他只是祝我们好运然后就走了。我们不知道那是什么意思。这是第一点。第二点，是《星期日泰晤士报》几年后提出的，《星期日泰晤士报》声称阿根廷
government had shipped 35,000 tons of grain to Peru and released $50 million in frozen Peruvian assets. So that's conspiracy theory number two. And conspiracy number three, which was made by a left-wing former Peruvian senator, he said it was actually part of the condor plan which was the south american kind of thing of murdering dissidents with sort of cia help he said that basically we in peru had sent the argentines 13 people to be tortured because the argentines were absolute specialists in this but the argentines said they would torture them only if we threw the match yeah now the problem you know you mentioned you've mentioned jonathan wil, the historian of Argentine football. Wilson says in his book,
政府向秘鲁运送了35,000吨谷物，并解冻了5000万美元被冻结的秘鲁资产。这是阴谋论之二。阴谋之三是由一名左翼前秘鲁参议员提出的，他说这实际上是“秃鹰行动”的一部分，那是南美洲在CIA的帮助下暗杀异见人士的计划，他说基本上我们秘鲁曾向阿根廷人运送了13个人去接受酷刑，因为阿根廷人绝对是这方面的专家，但阿根廷人说，只有在我们故意输掉这场比赛的情况下，他们才会对这些人施刑。现在，问题在于，你提到了乔纳森·威尔逊，阿根廷足球史学家。威尔逊在他的书中说，
the problem with all these allegations is, A, as so often, there is absolutely no evidence. And B, the fact is that Peru actually were quite unlucky to lose 6-0. They started playing very well. They hit the post, which you can't contrive. You know, it's not possible to contrive that. As Trough says in his book, it's fair to say that either not all the Peruvians were in on it or some of them must have been exceptionally good actors.
所有这些指控的问题在于，第一，和往常一样，绝对没有任何证据。第二，事实是秘鲁人以0比3输球其实有点运气不佳。他们一开始踢得很好。他们击中了门柱，这是无法人为策划的。你知道，这是不可能策划出来的。正如特罗夫在他的书中说的那样，平心而论，要么并非所有秘鲁人都参与其中，要么其中一些人一定是演技极其精湛的演员。
So he says the Peruvian goalie makes a series of improbably good saves, which you wouldn't do if you were trying to throw the match. Okay. Well, so that's one conspiracy theory but my favorite conspiracy theory of all about the 978 world cup is that at the the final against the dutch yeah which is argentina against the dutch uh the one of the people who attended the final was dr josef Mengele. Oh, God almighty. I haven't heard this. Yeah. What was he apparently...
所以他说秘鲁门将做出了一系列不可思议的精彩扑救，如果你是故意输球的话，你是不会这么做的。好吧。好吧，那是一个阴谋论，但我关于1978年世界杯最喜欢的阴谋论是，在对阵荷兰的决赛那天，是的，也就是阿根廷对阵荷兰的比赛，观看了决赛的人之一是约瑟夫·门格勒博士。哦，天哪。我没听过这个。是的。他当时显然……
What influence could he possibly have on the... No, he'd just been, you know, he'd been invited by the Junta. Right. Because they thought he might enjoy it. Well, he probably would have enjoyed it. I mean, obviously, he'd be rooting for Argentina. He would have been.
他对……能有什么影响？不，他只是，你知道的，他被军政府邀请了。对。因为他们觉得他可能会喜欢。好吧，他可能确实会喜欢。我是说，很明显，他会支持阿根廷。他肯定会支持的。
So the Dutch, actually, the one thing I will say, we said everyone went, but the Dutch, the best Dutch player from 1974, Johan Cruyff, did not go to that World Cup. But it's not because of politics.
所以荷兰人，实际上，我要说的一点是，我们说过所有人都去了，但荷兰队1974年最好的球员约翰·克鲁伊夫没有去那届世界杯。但这并不是因为政治原因。
It's actually because his family had been through a terrible ordeal in Barcelona. They had been almost kidnapped and sort of held ransom. So he didn't want to go for personal reasons. He just didn't fancy going to Argentina. Argentina win that final 3-1 an extra time. I mean, to be honest, they are still a good team. I mean, it's not like the Argentine team of 1978 is not a good team. And they beat the Dutch.
实际上是因为他的家人在巴塞罗那经历了一场可怕的磨难。他们差点被绑架并勒索赎金。所以他出于个人原因不想去。他只是不想去阿根廷。阿根廷在加时赛中以3比1赢得了那场决赛。我是说，说实话，他们确实是一支不错的球队。我是说，并不是说1978年的阿根廷队不是一支好球队。他们击败了荷兰队。
It's a very sort of bitter, dirty game, but they beat them fair and square. Videla, the head of the regime, hands over the trophy. The punches, the ticker tape. I mean, the ticker tape is incredible from the stands, these blizzards of sort of white and blue. But it's the stories about what happens next that are really kind of unpleasant. So the place where you were tortured if you were a dissident was the Navy Petty Officers School of Mechanics.
那是一场非常痛苦、充满粗野动作的比赛，但他们堂堂正正地击败了对手。独裁政权首脑魏地拉颁发了奖杯。礼炮，彩带。我是说，看台上的彩带太壮观了，白蓝两色的纸屑像暴风雪一样落下。但关于接下来发生的事的故事才真是相当令人不快。如果你是个异见人士，你遭受酷刑的地方就是海军军士学校机械学院。
And that was close enough to the stadium, the Monumental in Buenos Aires, that you could hear the crowd roaring. And the guards would put on the commentary on their radio so the prisoners could hear it. But a lot of the prisoners found it very distressing because they realized that this was a great victory for the junta. And they realized...
而且那里离布宜诺斯艾利斯的纪念碑球场足够近，你能听到人群的呐喊声。狱警们会在收音机里播放比赛解说，好让囚犯们也能听到。但许多囚犯觉得这非常痛苦，因为他们意识到这对军政府来说是一场伟大的胜利。他们意识到...
They're cheering the Argentine team team but they're also cheering and they realized how little how little the public were thinking about them that they were all thinking about the football and the story goes that um at the end of the final the torturers are celebrating next to their their victims so there's a guy called el tigre captain acosta who's one of the most notorious who makes a point of listening to the match with his his victims but then in a really sort of sinister development some of the torturers get some of the prisoners and they take them out of the prison in a peugeot 504 they take them out to tour buenos Aires, to see the people celebrating, to sort of show them the support. The love for the region.
他们在为阿根廷队欢呼，但他们也在欢呼，并且他们意识到公众是多么不在乎他们，大家关心的全都是足球。有个故事说，嗯，在决赛结束时，酷刑施虐者在他们的受害者旁边庆祝，有个叫埃尔蒂格雷的阿科斯塔队长，他是最臭名昭著的人之一，他特意和受害者一起听比赛。但随后，在一个非常阴险的发展中，一些施虐者带着一些囚犯，开着一辆标致504把他们带出监狱，带到布宜诺斯艾利斯兜风，去看人们庆祝，以此向他们展示支持，展示对政权的热爱。
And they even take them for a pizza. And one of them, the prisoners, is a woman called Graciela D'Aleo. And she puts her head through the sunroof of the car, looks out of the roof at all the people. And she said later, I stood up on that seat and I looked at the multitude. It was a moment of terrible solitude i was crying and i was certain that if i began to shout that i was one of the disappeared that no one would even notice yeah and and that is i mean that is a a kind of preview of the emotions i guess that the families of the laborers who died building the stadia in Qatar will
他们甚至带他们去吃披萨。其中一个囚犯是一位名叫加夫列拉·达莱奥的女性。她把头探出汽车的天窗，看着屋顶外的人群。她后来回忆说：“我站在那个座位上，看着人山人海。那是孤独至极的一刻，我在哭泣，我确信如果我大喊我是失踪人员之一，根本不会有人注意到。”是的，我的意思是，这可以说是对某种情绪的预演，我想，那些在卡塔尔建造体育场时死去的劳工家属们在...
be feeling when the ticker tape comes down at the final and all that. So, um, as we say, the story of the world cup is about so much more than sport. I mean, sport is incredibly important, but it's important not least because of the uses to which it can be
当决赛时的彩带落下以及所有这一切发生时，他们也会有这种感觉。所以，嗯，正如我们所说，世界杯的故事远不止于体育。我的意思是，体育极其重要，但它之所以重要，不仅是因为它可以被利用的那些用途，
put and we'll be talking about this tomorrow won't we because so tomorrow tom um we will be welcoming onto the podcast uh somebody who's played at a world cup and not just played at a world cup got hat trick yeah well more than hat trick was the top scorer at the 1986 world cup and that is the former england captain gary lineker who's now the face of football in this country, in Britain, but he's also very closely involved with the World Cup. I mean, he presented the draw in the Kremlin in 2018, and he'll be talking about that with us. He'll be talking about his thoughts about having the World Cup in Qatar,
我们明天会讨论这个，对吧？因为明天，汤姆，我们将迎来一位曾参加过世界杯的嘉宾，而且不仅仅是参加过世界杯，还上演了帽子戏法，哦，不仅仅是帽子戏法，他是1986年世界杯的最佳射手，那就是前英格兰队长加里·莱因克尔。如今他是英国足球的代名词，但他与世界杯也有着非常紧密的联系。我是说，他在2018年克里姆林宫的抽签仪式上担任过主持，他将与我们讨论此事。他将谈论他对在卡塔尔举办世界杯的想法，
about what the World Cup says about history and politics in the last few decades. And then once we've talked to Gary, Tom, we'll be embarking on our 32-episode marathon. Yes, we will. About aspects of history from the competing countries, from the White Rose Movement in Germany to, what is it, prehistoric Serbia? Yes, possibly the invention of writing in Serbia in 5,500 BC.
谈谈世界杯在过去几十年里对历史和政治意味着什么。然后，在和加里聊过之后，汤姆，我们将开启我们的32集马拉松之旅。是的，我们会的。关于参赛国家的历史方方面面，从德国的白玫瑰运动到，什么来着，史前塞尔维亚？是的，可能是公元前5500年塞尔维亚文字的发明。
And I have to say that doing podcasts on aspects of his 32 countries, lots of which, Dominic, I think we should put our hands up and say we're not particularly familiar with, that for us it's been an incredible it's been an incredible yeah brilliant process of discovery it has uh a cameroonian a cameroonian general who fought for peter the great um slavery in senegal uh the history of qatar uh the ashanti yeah uh the maid of holl. The Costa Rican Civil War, Tom. Oh, yes, yes, with Dr. Valverde and Don Pepe. Yes.
我得说，制作关于这32个国家各方面历史的播客——多米尼克，我想我们应该坦白承认，其中许多国家我们其实并不是特别熟悉——对我们来说，这是一次不可思议的、不可思议的、精彩的探索历程。确实如此，一个为彼得大帝战斗过的喀麦隆将军，塞内加尔的奴隶制，卡塔尔的历史，阿散蒂，还有霍尔的少女，哥斯达黎加内战，汤姆。哦，是的，是的，还有巴尔瓦德雷医生和多恩·佩佩。
The Somerton Man, Australia's most intriguing murder mystery story. Essentially, when I look back, I mean, Tom and I have spent, you know, months. Years of our life. We started doing it in August. Did we start recording in August? I think we did, yeah, recording these podcasts. And we can't wait to release them to an unsuspecting world i know they'll just keep rolling forward like um dutch footballers in 1974 just hope that we uh we get a slightly better result than they did yes who are the germans in this analogy that's
萨顿人，澳大利亚最离奇的谋杀悬案。基本上，当我回首往事时，我和汤姆已经花了，你知道的，好几个月。我们生命的几年。我们从八月开始做这件事。我们是八月开始录制的吗？我想是的，是的，开始录制这些播客。我们迫不及待地想要把它们发布给毫无防备的世界，我知道它们会一直滚动推出，就像1974年的荷兰球员那样，只希望我们的结果能比他们稍微好一点。等等，这个比喻里的德国人是谁？这是一个...
a terrible let's not answer that question. There are no other podcasts, right? We will see you tomorrow when we will be joined by Gary Lineker. And until then, thank you very much. And goodbye. Bye. Bye. Thanks for listening to the rest is. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
糟糕的问题，我们还是别回答了。没有别的播客了，对吧？我们明天见，届时加里·莱因克尔将加入我们。在那之前，非常感谢大家，再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《The Rest Is...》。想要收听额外单集、提前抢先听、无广告收听，
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A
以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》，这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料，还有我们的问答环节
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets
我们将带你揭开娱乐产业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场演出门票的权限，
head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。